Hello!
Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Welcome!
Today is a special stream today!
If you guys didn't know, I'm sponsored by Senuality slash Bandai to check out their Closed Network Test.
So, some of you guys, dragoons, might have already played this already because it came out.
The Closed Network Test was out yesterday.
So, for those who registered for the Closed Network Test, you might have been lucky to try it out yesterday.
I chose today because I didn't realize it came out yesterday.
So, I was like, the 14th.
That's really it.
I was like, I chose 14th.
I was literally like, which day do I do it?
I was like, the 14th because I bet that's the first day it's out.
And then they're like, well, and then I found out.
I was like, oh, wait, it comes out on the 18th.
I was like, what?
Well, it's too late.
I already tweeted it out.
All right, you know what?
I tweeted out the whole, like, hey, guys, I'm going to check out Senuality on September 14th.
All right, and then after I tweeted that out, I was like, wait, that's day two.
I was like, wait, the 13th is when it comes out.
Well, I already tweeted it.
I can't just be like, JK, let me reschedule that.
Anyhow, I'm a professional right here.
I am a fucking professional.
So, yes, I am going in blind.
I have not played the game yet.
The only thing I know is that it's related to mechas.
So, I am going in blind.
I know there's some pew-pewing going on, too.
So, like, it's mechas and there's pew-pew.
So, I'm going in with a blind reaction to it and let you guys see what the game is all about.
And also, because...
It's very fitting that we have this, too.
Get in the robot dragons!
I felt like it's very fitting that we have this today for this stream especially.
So, I just felt like, you know, it's good timing, you know?
Good timing.
Congratulations.
S였습니다.
Um... what other stuff do I wanna... Okay, also... life update.
I cheat went out today!
I win out!
Uh, usually.
I know this is a sponsored stream, but I wanna give you guys a life update, too.
I might be paid to do the stream, but it doesn't mean I won't give you guys an update on my life.
It doesn't exempt from giving life updates.
Um, I'm actually touch grass!
You know, like, ever since moving out...
Ever since moving out.
I'm going out to a new place.
I've been super... in the past, I would not go out when I have days where I'm streaming.
So... but like lately, the past couple of weeks, I've been going out and like actually going out doing stuff.
Outside of just like stream... like on stream days as well.
So today I went to a farmer's market.
It was nice.
I got some... I got some stuff at farmer's market.
I actually went to a farmer's market today.
And I bought a lot of bread.
Guys, okay.
I know I could Google this.
But like why Google when I... you guys can tell me.
But how long before bread expires?
Like...
How long?
I bought a lot of bread.
I bought a lot of baked... bakery stuff.
So like... how long before they expire?
Wait, do I freeze it?
I bought a lot.
I... I...
I bought way too much.
I bought like two bags of like bakery things.
Because I was like, ooh, fresh bread.
But like... but like can I just eat bakery things for like the next two or three days?
Like for lunch and dinner?
And then like I'll just survive off that?
Or should I freeze it now?
Or do I put it in the fridge?
Freeze it and it can last for...
Forever?
Okay.
You can... yeah.
You can freeze bread?
Yeah.
You can... apparently... apparently you can freeze bread.
Two weeks in the fridge.
Oh!
So I can live off of...
You know what?
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna live off of...
I'm gonna live off of baked goods for the next two weeks.
I'm gonna...
I could...
Whoa!
This looks so good.
I was like... oh my god.
The closest bakery near me is so far.
Well, to be fair, the closest bakery next... near me is not that far.
But then, like, when you're at a farmer's market, you buy a lot of stuff, you know, from...
I don't know if they're actually farmers, but like...
You buy a lot of food.
And I was like...
Whoa!
Fresh bread?
I mean, it's not gonna be fresh after I fucking put it in the fridge.
But like...
Whoa!
Fresh baked goods?
So then I bought...
A lot.
Cause I...
I was like...
Wow!
I am...
Making good business decisions.
So, look, I'm...
It's not like...
Guys, I didn't buy that much.
Two bags does not equal three months of food, guys.
It doesn't...
It doesn't equal three months of food.
I think it'll last me, like, maybe a week.
If I eat it for lunch and dinner for the next week...
For the next week, I think we'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
Alright.
So...
We will...
I'll basically have a bread diet for the next two weeks.
I don't know if that's healthy.
There's no meat...
I don't...
I have chicken.
So, like...
If anything, I will...
I will...
Add protein if I need to.
Cause I'm thinking, like, that's not that healthy if I just eat bread the entire time.
But it's really good bread!
It's, like, all natural bread!
It was made by an old lady!
So, I assume...
It was made by, like, an old Asian granny.
So, like, I assume it's really good bread.
Well, it was made by, like, several grannies.
So, like, I assume it's really, really good bread.
Uh...
But, yes.
I bought two bags worth of bread.
There was so many!
There was so many stalls at the farmer market that were just selling bread!
I can't help it!
There...
It was, like...
There were several...
It was a farmer's market!
Guys!
It was so...
Every other stall was, like, bakery...
Good...
Bakery stuff.
So, I was, like, wow!
It wasn't just bread.
I also bought...
I bought cookies, too.
But, like, I was, like, wow!
It's not bread bread!
It was, like, baked...
You know, it has some form of bread in it.
I, like...
And I also bought honey, too.
So...
It...
It smelled really good.
Okay.
It smelled really nice.
So, I couldn't help myself.
Like, won't it go...
That's why I was, like...
It was a...
It was a bad idea that I bought two bags, but I...
There was...
It was so many.
Like...
It looked really good.
Some of them were shaped like cute animals.
Like, can you really blame me?
There was one that was shaped like a cute animal.
It was shaped like a bear.
I was, like, oh my god!
I need that!
I...
I need...
Anyway.
So, today I went to the farmer's market.
Another life of...
Yeah.
I've been going outside a lot more lately in the last couple of weeks, which I...
Which has been really nice in general because, like, you know, I feel like I have a lot more energy to actually go outside now.
And it was nice to go to the farmer's market and just, you know, look around.
Look at the food.
And just look at the...
Just buy two bags of bread.
And...
Especially on a stream day, too.
It did not feel like a stream day for me today.
So, like, it was really nice to just go outside during stream day.
Like, not be worried.
Being like, oh, I have to be at home.
I have to be at home and, like, prepare for the stream.
And, like, just focus on work, work, work.
So, it's nice to, like, have half the day just going outside and relaxing a little bit before coming back to stream the day.
So, it was a nice change of pace, you know.
But, yeah.
Another life update.
Doki Amber Doge, a.k.a.
Dad, has found out that the bathroom floor has heated tiles.
This is not good for me.
Why do you ask?
It's not good for me.
Because he found out today.
Because I...
And, you know, it's getting closer.
It's getting...
It's fall now.
So...
And the summer's over.
So, it's fall now.
And...
So, the bathroom floor has heated tiles...
So...
And he...
He basically...
I would use the bathroom.
I use the bathroom today.
And then he went inside, and I was, like, leave.
I was, like, Doki, now leave.
And then he looked at me and sat down.
I am a Doki.
And then I tried pushing his butt to the door, cause like, the thing is, the wish part is my bathroom door, my bathroom door cannot fully close, it always has like, if he pushes the door, it opens, so like, he can open doors if you don't fully close, if you don't fully close the door,
he knows how to open doors.
All he does is just push the door, and so, and so, so, so, anyway, anyway, so he found out the towels are heated, so I was like, leave, and then he just looks at me, and just sits down, and I push him out, with my, I was like, leave, and I push him out,
and he just sits there, and looks at me.
And then, and then, like, and then I'll be, and I opened the door, and was like, please, dad, please, go, and then he just, he walks to the door, and then looks at me, and then lies down, and I'm like, are you fucking serious?
Am I getting serious?
I'm just like, oh my god, anyway, so yes.
Now he knows the towels are heated, and now that it's starting to get colder, it's starting to get colder here in Canada, I am very afraid of life, I'm very afraid now.
All right, anyway, Senuality, Echo of Ada, life update over, time for the sponsored portion.
I want to say again, huge thank you to Bandai.
For, uh, for the sponsor, I really appreciate, um, I really appreciate, um, them sponsoring me to check out this game, um, we're looking forward to it, I really am, um, like I said, I heard there's, like, mechas, and there's pew-pew, so it's perfect for me.
Uh, did you guys know here about Transformers 1?
I heard, like, I heard it was really, I heard it was really good, um, um, from the reviews.
All right, enter player name.
Not Doki Bird.
All right, you can use up to six, is this six?
One, two, guys, I don't think this is six.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Okay.
Wait, oh, I can!
Oh, digits is numbers!
Sorry, I'm illiterate.
That's, sorry, I'm, I'm illiterate.
Yeah, okay.
You'll never expect it's me, because it says not Doki Bird.
All right, let me know the volumes, okay?
Oh, no.
The Drifters?
Wait, is that co- voice coming out of that thing?
Tears of the New Moon?
Who is this handsome little critter?
Who is this little child doing a donut here?
Oh, this is the place I was going to think about, when I was a kid with Boss Lamp.
If they smile, they're crazy kids.
When can fashionable kids playое?
I love to play.
How's that thing called again?
Stop!
Leave him alone!
He's just trying to be a cool guy!
That's us!
We're the Drifters!
We're heroes!
Of course we cannot forget the Human Duality Cognitive Androids, Magus.
Oh, the sound guy, is it better now?
We have become a necessary part of our world.
And soon we'll be fully integrated into our daily lives.
Oh, so they're cyborgs!
We just talk on the back of our bipedal mecha, helping to power them.
This is called...
The Cradle Coffins!
Precisely, Yoshio.
Thanks for the Cradle Coffins.
That's us!
The heroic Drifters were able to face even harsher conditions than ever before.
That's nice!
Every mecha has a waifu.
To work with their Magus and master the Cradle Coffins.
To battle humanity's greatest enemy, the Enders.
And gather the precious AO Crystals.
Let us continue to fight for the glory of the...
The robot waifus!
However, due to the chaos following the collapse of Amasia, some...
That's cool!
We have robot waifus and then we have mecha waifus!
We have the best of both worlds!
...and a dark side to society.
Without electricity, how is Yoshio supposed to make food?
How is the mecha supposed to work?
Drifter Support Association comes in.
Wait, without electricity, then how would the mechas work?
Regular AO Crystal excavation and trade.
So that every human has equal access to our precious energy.
Oh!
Thank you Drifter Support Association!
So they have all the power!
So listen up, all you cool kids who want to be cool Drifters!
Are you a cool kid?
You want to join the army?
It's like whatever plans he has.
It's like the army using anime girls.
To recruit people.
To recruit soldiers.
Hello fellow children.
Would you like to sign up?
To represent your country?
We have anime girls.
And the recruiter.
...
The lineup sequence complete.
Display incoming.
Good.
First, check your visuals.
Check my visuals?
Look for the three displays.
Okay.
Oh, alright let's...
Okay, let me adjust the sensitivity real quick.
Okay, give me...
Oh, escape?
Oh, I can't yet.
I have to do the camera first.
Am I doing it correctly?
Clear!
I did it!
Okay.
Sorry, I wasn't looking at the right thing.
I partially did it.
Oh, nice!
It took me to the audio settings right off the bat!
Thank god!
I'm gonna get three... I'm gonna turn that down.
And I think it should be fine.
I think.
Okay, confirm.
Yeah, that's convenient, actually.
I really like that.
Wait, did it not confirm?
Oh, I have to do return!
Okay.
I'm gonna go outside for the first time?
I'm gonna touch grass?
Okay.
I got you.
Batteries deplete the longer they are used, so keep an eye on the clock so you can make a safe return to the underground.
Alternatively, you can use a spare battery to recharge.
Okay.
Here I go.
Alright.
Don't worry, I'm heading over.
I'm jumping.
Okay.
My range is not that far.
Wait, I wanna customize her.
I don't like her.
Sorry!
You can customize her, right?
To make, like, your perfect waifu.
I wanna make a better waifu.
Keep an eye on your temps.
I have a bunch of things to say!
What do you mean?!
I want my robot waifu to look like the girl in the picture!
I want...
What do you think?
I wanna dress up my waifu!
Oh my god.
Woah.
Give me a sec.
Use all your search to find crystals.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean that.
Please let me...
Please stop lagging me.
I didn't mean that.
You're so beautiful.
I didn't...
I didn't mean that!
Please.
I didn't mean that.
Don't lag me.
I swear.
I did not mean that!
This is what you get.
Okay.
Oh, please.
Woman, please.
I'm sorry.
Detected.
Go to the location shown at the top right of your display.
Okay.
Let me... let me fix this.
Let me fix this.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Oh, no.
Where's the graphics?
Oh, it's not because we're in tutorial.
It's because we're in tutorial.
Okay.
Bring up the sound effects by 80.
Alright.
Nice.
No graphics.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it.
I'm so sorry.
Please give me the graphics settings.
I would never change you.
You're beautiful.
You're so beautiful.
I would never change you.
Please don't lock the graphics settings.
Don't...
Don't lock the graphics settings.
They took away my graphics setting privileges.
They took it away.
Okay.
Tips.
Range weapons can be split into two categories.
Can be split into those that use energy and those that use live ammo.
Weapons... Oh, my God.
Please.
I'm so sorry.
I'm... I'm so sorry.
Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry, ma'am.
Please don't take away my privileges.
Oh, shit.
I did it ever since I insult today.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I deserve that.
Honestly, I deserve it.
Okay.
I deserve that chat.
I'll never insult a beautiful robot waifu again.
I'll never insult this beautiful anime robot waifu again.
Oh, I have to execute.
Oh nice, got a drill.
Don't you forget it.
It only happened because I said I wanted to customize her and make her more beautiful, but she was already beautiful inside and out.
She was already... she was already beautiful and it only took her to take away my frame privileges to realize how beautiful she is, no matter what.
Okay, nice.
I got a grab.
Oh, I got rare!
Return elevator?
Use return points to summon an elevator and ride it?
Okay.
How do I... oh I can emote though.
Wait, I can't emote.
Wait, how do I take the return... Oh it's on the other side!
Okay.
Is it?
Where is it?
Where is the...
It's here!
There's like a yellow over there.
No, I won't customize her.
She's...
She's beautiful.
Wait, what's wrong with rain?
What's wrong with rain?
Oh, I forgot it's acid rain.
I forgot the whole story was that the rain is poisonous!
I'm like, what's wrong with that?
What's wrong?
It is a non-perious effect of weather.
Once your weather reaches zero, you will become to the environment.
Be careful of how much damage your unit takes.
Okay.
Thank you.
I will never replace you, I swear.
That's fast!
That's really fast!
For like...
Oh wait, okay, never mind.
Okay, I was going to say, did it stop raining?
But it didn't.
Okay.
Jeez.
This is why I hate rain.
Please stop talking.
Please!
Robot wife!
I need you to stop talking because I need to shoot him!
Sorry, I didn't mean you...
Sorry, you're perfect.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean that.
But ma'am, I'm taking damage.
I'm really taking damage right now while you're talking.
There's a tab in place for everything.
My beautiful robot waifu.
Who I'll never replace.
Okay.
Alright, do that.
Alright, return request.
What?
Elevator will arrive in five seconds.
Okay, I was going to say like...
What?
Board with care.
Guys...
Am I...
Am I doing it?
Oh.
Is he going to take me?
Oh, it's downstairs!
Oh!
What?
I thought it was going to...
Okay.
I forgot elevator goes down.
I'm on the roof.
I'm on the fucking roof.
I was just like...
Am I... Am I going to go downstairs?
I can customize... Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Wait.
There's husbandos too?
Oh my god, they have everything!
They have waifus and husbandos!
Guys!
They have...
They have, you know...
They have the anime girl that's on the cover.
And then they have the second anime girl that was not on the cover.
Cause she's not good enough.
Popular for it's dawnless attitude even when faced with the unexpected treats as you know.
A firm countenance to ensure they stay out.
What's her... She has a playful side.
But it's sharp wits at end.
Oh!
I could get this guy for Shinji and be like...
Okay.
We're going to go with the girl on the cover.
Alright.
We're going to go with the...
Or we could get him.
So we can wear this.
So we can...
Or we get him.
What should we do?
Alright.
Do we get...
Do we get low B-O-3 or G-R-A-X-O-1 3 You coward!
How weird!
As both a lover of fighting games and grapplers, you may both say jazz slaps if you participate.
Didn't.
You made a new fan.
Thank you for the super chat.
AJ, thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you enjoyed it.
Alright guys.
3?
You want 3?
But she's on the cover!
And she's not!
Chat.
Why is 4 not an option?
You are like the 1% right now.
You're like literally the 1%.
This guy should be in the robot, not like fucking guiding the robot.
Alright.
Okay, we're gonna vote.
I'll make a poll for you guys.
I'll make a poll.
Okay.
How do we pick the one on the bottom right?
Which robot waifu?
1, 2, 3.
Okay, I should I almost like got rid of 3 and just put 4.
Okay guys.
Select your waifu slash husbendo.
Maybe they will treat me better than the last tutorial robot waifu.
You actually won!
But she's not on the cover!
She's not!
Wait, what the fuck is this?
Oh, it like gives them their Is this B for beta?
Wait, is this Wait, is this Is this the beta sign?
Is this actually But look, she should be Yes!
Wait, is this beta?
Oh my Even
this game you're a fucking beta.
It's the Greek letter.
Wait, what's her Greek letter?
Is this alpha?
Wait, is this Is this alpha?
Oh my god, she's alpha!
Wait, what's this?
Wait, is he also beta?
Oh my god!
This is also beta!
I don't care.
Like, that's funny.
Yeah, she's an alpha.
Alright, five.
We'll go with three.
I like how two has nine percent.
There's people voting for four for the two.
This poor guy.
This poor man.
Okay.
We're gonna go.
We'll go with three.
Chat.
Okay.
Create a support.
Displays a rain cloud radar system specialized in increases repair kit speed.
Oh!
She could be my support!
Anti-enders a system specializes in anti-ender combat.
Displays ender health.
Features a skill that facilitates multi-attack.
Okay, anti-cradle.
Defends.
Turn more towards...
Okay, I feel like... We get support?
Support our enders.
Because this one gives me more attack for the monsters.
And...
PvP?
Guys, please don't beat me up, guys.
I...
Please don't!
Please don't try to find me and beat me up, guys!
I joined on day two!
You guys had day one!
This is my day one!
This is...
Okay.
Alright, we'll get support.
Well, I feel like a lot of dragons are... Oh, I can customize her!
What the fuck?
Okay, now I know why you guys said three.
Oh my god.
Can I have her take off her jacket?
Wait a minute!
Where can I make her?
Okay.
Let's get her.
Wait, what is...
Okay.
Alright.
Height.
Since she's Alpha.
You know, since she's Alpha...
You know, since...
Guys!
Because she's Alpha, guys!
Because she's Alpha!
Alright.
Let's see.
Hairstyle.
No, her hairstyle is perfect.
Honestly, her... Everything else is like perfect right now.
Honestly, I have no...
I have like no critiques on anything else.
What about eyes?
Eye color?
Contour?
Oh, there's...
Is there no eye... Oh, there is!
Eye color.
Oh...
Wait, what was it before?
Oh, it was this.
Actually, like...
I can't tell the difference.
Alright, wait.
Can I...
Oh, I think...
Oh my god.
The red though?
The red.
Actually...
No, I actually like the default a lot.
Alright, we'll confirm.
Can I take away her...
Appearance?
No.
Can I...
Oh, I can't.
Okay, I want to take away her jacket, but they won't let me.
They won't!
Oh, I can give her one of her eyes!
Uh...
Right eye color.
Okay.
We'll give that... Okay, no.
We'll give this one.
...
Yeah.
Oh, I don't know, actually.
I don't know if that looks good.
No, that's too much.
That's too much, guys.
The eye is too much, guys.
Yeah, no.
We're gonna keep it there.
That's too much of a red flag, guys.
That's too much of a red flag.
Okay.
I'm sad.
Alright.
What should we call her?
...
Alpha.
Okay.
Or no red flags.
...
Alpha real.
There you go.
Okay.
Real alpha.
...
Okay.
There you go.
Nice.
No!
Okay.
Here.
There you go.
Real alpha.
Nice.
Yay!
...
We picked her!
Oh my god.
We picked her.
...
Oh my god!
I got my own garage!
...
What could go wrong?
We have a real alpha on our team.
She speaks.
She's here to guide us.
How do I...
I honestly like her outfit more without the jacket.
...
She's not gonna let me down!
I literally just got it!
Like, why is she judging me?!
I just got here!
It's okay, she's a real athlete, she can judge me all she wants.
Oh!
That doesn't sound hard.
I got a job!
Guys!
Okay.
Maintenance.
Oh, that's just the main- Oh, there she is!
She's cleaning my garage!
Wow, Drifter, you live like this!
Thank you for the super chat!
I've tried my best here!
I literally just got here!
Welcome to the life of a brand new Drifter!
Drifter is a member of the Drifter Support Association.
You can expect a variety of requests from the association as well as other organizations.
Okay.
Completing requests earns you rewards.
The most achievements you racked up, the higher your evaluation would be, which unlocks new requests.
Okay.
It permits fighting other association members as a general rule.
If you intentionally and repeatedly attack- You hear that, guys?!
If you intentionally and repeatedly attack!
Association members, you will be expelled from the association!
So, if you attack me, i.e.
a member of our association, you will be kicked out!
That's all I'm saying.
I'm saying, if you want to keep your hot robot anime waifu, then you would think about, you know, not attacking your fellow association member!
Or you're gonna get hunted by Rensetsu!
Fucking- Oh, Miltian too?!
This game just came out!
How many fucking boundaries are there?!
This game literally came out yesterday!
The closed network test!
This guy is gonna fucking get you!
Wait, I can see their waifus!
How do their waifus look like?
Oh my god!
They actually gave- They're like- Oh my god!
Wait, I like how- I like how this is default.
They made- They didn't even customize her a lot.
They didn't even- Customize her?
Oh.
But then this guy went all out on the customization.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Oh, they gave her like a red- Oh, that's cute!
Yeah, this guy's default dad.
He's like- Thank god you can tell a lot about a person by what they made their character!
You can really- You can really tell a lot about- What kind of- What kind of waifu they want.
Oh, what kind of anime husband they want!
This guy doesn't care.
This guy's just here to grind.
I don't think he cared about customization chat.
This guy literally is just here to grind the game.
Like, everybody else is custom- This guy's just here.
He's just here.
But everybody else, you can tell a lot about the person.
With like, how they- How they customize.
I like how he's the only one with a guy, too.
He's like the only one with this guy.
Eleven- Oh, wait.
Okay.
I was like, what the fuck?
It's interesting.
Bro, I hope this guy gets top ten.
I hope- I hope- I hope he gets top ten!
Oh my god, he is- Holy shit.
He's almost there!
Guys!
We gotta hope this guy gets top ten!
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh my god, dragon killer.
I love- I love like, the customized- Guys!
I have not seen anybody use guy number two yet.
I- I actually haven't seen anybody use- Guy number two.
I saw two guy number fours.
But like, where's guy number two?
Is this guy number two- Is this guy number two?
Is that- Four- Is that him?
Wait, is that- That- Is that Beta- Beta?
Wait, there he is!
Beta two!
Oh my god!
I didn't recognize him at all!
I- To be fair, like, okay.
I- I should have recognized him when, you know...
I- I think I wanna- Oh, wait.
Okay.
Let's see, bro!
I- I didn't- Guys, I didn't look down.
I didn't look- I didn't look down, guys.
That was my issue.
Wait, I wanna- I really like this outfit.
Even though, like, I know it's her underwear.
But like, it's actually so cute.
Um, the innerwear there.
Oh!
That one- Wait, was it this one?
This one.
I think this is really cute!
I think this is so cute!
His shoes.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh!
Wait, that's so cute!
Oh, my God!
It looks like Dragon Ball with this!
Okay.
What about- Uh...
Uh...
What about the pants?
Okay, I- Guys!
Guys!
I know- It's actually so cute!
Like, I know this is like, technically her underwear, but it's such a cute outfit!
It's actually really cute!
Okay, I'm gonna keep this.
I actually really like this.
Alright, request.
What am I supposed to do?
So you're new.
We'll just find the crystals.
Oh, we've done this before!
We've done the crystals.
Yeah, I did it!
Hello fellow kids.
So hold on to your cradles and check this out.
Welcome, Rookie Drifter.
Today I'll be explaining everything you need to...
That's cute.
Out there, your cradle and Magus are your best friends.
So let's head out for a nice stroll on the surface.
We're best friends!
Take note of where materials can be found.
She's forced to be my friend because she was made just for me.
And keep your eyes out for the ever important AO Crystals.
Collect those AO Crystals because you can exchange them for cash.
But get beat up by an enemy.
And you lose all the stuff you found.
That's so cute.
I like the animation.
Find the nearest elephant.
Yeah, it's a pug suit.
Exactly, Miracle.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's not underwear, guys.
Technically...
Since they are a robot...
The skin is a robot's underwear.
So like...
The clothes above it...
Is technically clothes.
If you think about it.
Because the skin is a robot underwear.
If you think about it, guys.
Okay.
Oh, I can watch you sleep.
I didn't mean to sound creepy, but...
Wait, wish list?
Register...
Oh my gosh, can I put...
Okay.
Collect... withdraw money.
Lock, collect supplies.
Item...
Guys, robots don't sleep, guys.
How can I watch something that doesn't sleep?
What's this?
Oh!
Oh, it's like extraction.
So like...
This is my inventory.
Repair kit.
Sealing kit.
Small ammunition.
So I can buy these.
Oh wait, no.
These are my storage.
So I get...
All this in my storage...
For now.
I feel like I'm gonna keep all of this for now.
Oh my gosh, she's making me mushrooms.
What the fuck you doing?
You don't need to eat.
We have limited...
Eating is cosmetics for you.
It's just recreation.
It's food.
You don't know that.
She's a robot.
She doesn't...
She just needs battery.
What do you mean?
I can't afford to feed both of us.
She's testing for poison.
It's called biofuel.
Oh, there's insurance.
I can have my stuff.
Guys, please don't kill me.
I'm not insured, guys.
Guys, I'm not insured.
Please do not kill me.
Please.
I have no insurance, guys.
I have no health insurance and I'm visiting America.
Okay, with the completion of the Great Shield, a base for drifters was also established inside the vertical shaft and the surrounding region was quickly stabilized.
Dorms for the construction workers were also created inside the shaft and subsequent work proceeded quickly.
But also, when around 80% of the construction work on the residential districts have...
Oh, okay.
So I'll never know what happened after.
Okay, that's me.
No, it's raining.
Why is it raining?
I really just got here.
Is there any crystals?
Okay.
Okay, where...
Alright, don't worry.
I got you.
I got a monster.
Okay, so he is melee.
Where the fuck are all the crystals?
Did you guys steal all the crystals?
Oh, shit.
Nice.
I got loot.
Guys, I need to remind... I am not insured, guys.
I... Please, guys.
I am... I'm not insured, guys.
I need... Please, everybody.
I'm not insured, so please.
Where is he?
There's the crystal.
This enemy is known as a chaser.
These things are quick.
Keep your head on a swivel.
What if I just shoot it?
What is he gonna do?
Kill me?
Is there any...
He is not dead.
What is he gonna do?
Jump up?
Bro, he's just down there.
He can't do jack shit.
Like, what is he gonna do?
Jump?
So easy.
I'm just gamer.
Okay, we need to figure out where the crystals are.
Alright.
AO search.
I'm not detecting any new AO crystal readings.
No crystals anywhere?
Robot waifu!
How am I gonna provide for our robot family?
I'm, like, scared of, like, actually going... like, using my speed.
Cause, like, what if...
Oh, another chaser.
Don't worry, I got you.
Check the map.
The map just gives me the elevators.
I have to search.
I detect faint gunfire.
Faint gunfire?
Oh, no.
No, no, they're here.
Guys, we're working in the same association, guys.
Just remember that we are working together.
We are part of the same team.
Okay, I think we're okay, right?
I do hear, like, gunshots.
Gunshots nearby.
I'm trying to find... guys, please, I'm on my first mission, guys.
There's still no crystals anywhere.
Did you guys take all the crystals?
Wait, is there fall damage?
Well, time to find out.
Damage is catastrophic.
Be ready to bail out.
You should perform repairs in a safe area.
Guys, can you...
Guys, please don't...
Guys, there's... guys, there's...
Guys, we're out.
Guys, there's fall damage.
How do I...
I don't have repairs.
Guys, there's fall damage.
Guys, please, I swear to God.
No!
What do you mean?
It starts raining!
What the fuck do you mean it starts raining?
How do I fucking... how do I heal myself?
Confirm.
Oh, no.
I detect a faint sound.
What's the button?
An Ender has detected us.
No!
Fable detected.
Ender incoming.
Now, sustained.
Oh, no.
Nice aim.
Ender has sustained damage.
Oh, God.
Okay, okay.
How do I heal?
Age, okay.
Wait, I thought he could heal me.
He not heal me?
Is that your heal?
Don't you have an ability?
The system has been recovered in full.
I used the wrong one.
I forgot green goes to green.
Green goes to green.
Detected by a chaser.
Green is green, blue is blue.
Okay, we're learning, guys.
Okay.
Is there a crystal?
I'm not detecting any new enemies.
How is there no crystal?
Did you guys take all the crystals I just got here?
Okay, what's this?
Oh, a sheet.
Metal sheet.
Looks like a mild drizzle.
Alright, mild drizzle.
Green goes to green, guys.
You guys didn't know that.
See, I can swap my gun.
What gun is this?
This is a better gun.
Make a skill primed and ready to go.
You can now deploy a field that will recover durability.
Really?
The weather's gotten better.
Oh, it's like these items have cooldowns.
I see.
I see now.
Oh my god, why is there so much acid rain everywhere?
AO search.
Please.
I'm not detecting any new AO crystal readings.
How is there still no crystals?
How is there still no...
Guys, please.
I just need crystals.
Stop farming all the crystals, guys.
Guys, okay.
I found out there's fall damage, so...
If I could get on this rope...
Explore.
I'm trapped.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, copper scrap.
Oh my god, rare find.
This is quite a rare item.
Okay.
Let's see.
I thought this was open, not gonna lie.
Oh, I don't have any room.
What's more important?
Oh, I do have room.
Oh, I can carry like two more pounds.
Wait, is that red, a crystal?
AO search.
I'm not detecting any new AO crystals.
Is that red?
No, it's not.
Another chaser?
Okay.
This is... I don't know.
I don't know if this gun is better or not.
Okay, it's not.
I can't tell.
I think the recoil is not the best.
I might use the light ammo.
Is this PvP?
If you want to be kicked out of the association...
It's not PvP, guys.
It's...
Guys, it's not PvP, guys.
It's not PvP.
I like to say it's not PvP, chat.
If you're in my lobby right now, it's not PvP.
Another chaser?
Yeah, I like this gun more.
I'm running out of ammo, though.
Like, I'm actually running out of ammo.
Oh, it's PvE, everybody.
If you're a dragoon, it's PvE.
How is there still no...
What do you mean there's still no... I fucking...
I walked so far.
Real alpha.
There is melee.
It's E.
E is melee.
See?
But I'm like... I'm literally trying to find...
A crawler.
A crawler?
Watch out.
What the fuck is a crawler?
Wait, is that crystal?
Is that fucking crystal?
What the fuck is going on?
Where are they going?
It's raining.
Oh, it's because it's raining.
Okay.
Oh my god, I think that's a crystal.
Guys.
Guys, I...
Guys, I found the first crystal.
Guys, oh my god.
The one crystal.
The...
The one...
Fucking...
Finally...
Oh my god, there's so many!
Wait, that's not a crystal.
That's...
That's not a crystal.
Sorry.
Wait, is that a crystal?
Where is it?
Where the fuck is this...
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god.
That's what it looks like.
Please.
Please get away.
Oh god.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
We found...
Fucking finally found the crystal.
We need one more.
We literally need one more crystal.
Oh no.
It's okay.
They'll repair me.
Oh no.
I have only 57 bullets left.
What are they looking at?
What the fuck is going on for this guy?
He's just jumping.
Okay.
Goddammit!
You guys farmed everything!
It's okay.
My armor can repair itself later.
Guys, my armor is not repairing itself.
It's...
I'm just trying to find the one crystal.
Why is it always...
Who fucked up the environment?
Why not?
Oh god.
Who did this?!
Guys, I have no ammo.
I've been here so long trying to fucking find this one crystal.
One last crystal.
Get out!
Oh shit, okay.
Okay, this is bad.
This is bad.
I need a repair.
You repair me here?
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, who fucked up this environment?
Okay, I need to find this crystal.
The last crystal.
Guys, I don't... there's no cover, guys.
It's over.
There's no cover.
Wait, what's this?
Is she gonna heal me?
Oh!
Oh nice!
I'm getting healed.
Oh, that's the ability!
That's the support cradle!
That's what I was trying to find earlier.
Oh!
Okay, that's actually really good.
What the?
Oh shit, I'm sorry!
Ah, that's the best thing!
I'm sorry!
We're friends!
I'm sorry, you scared me!
You scared me!
Please!
I worked... Please, I'm so sorry!
Please, you scared me!
Please, no!
Please!
Oh, it's abandoned?
Oh, thank god.
I thought he was a... I thought... guys, there's no PvP, by the way.
I'm not scared because I thought he was a real...
Guys, I... guys, there's no PvP.
It's not because I was... I was scared that this was another real person.
Okay?
I just need you guys to know that.
Okay...
Um, no, we're okay.
We're... we're okay.
Oh my god, I guess I'll go downstairs then.
There must be like... it must be downstairs because I don't see anything from... um...
Um, I don't see anything downstairs... like upstairs here.
So it has to be down here, right?
I just need one... one tiny crystal.
Literally, I'm missing one.
Only ten more minutes.
Wait, I only have ten... it's fine.
There's no way I can fuck this up.
Please... please, Robot Waifu, I need one more crystal.
That's all I need.
That's all I fucking need.
Go check under the rocks.
I'm scanning, though.
I should be able to find it from just scanning.
Okay.
It has to be one.
There has to be one.
They can't fuck with me like this.
You guys... you guys are taking a... took everything.
Like, this is a barren wasteland now.
Everybody else on day one fucking scavenged this land.
There's nothing left.
Chaser...
Okay, that doesn't matter.
How is there...
How far do I have to fucking go?
There's no way it sees me, right?
What the fuck is that?
Does it see me?
Okay, nice.
Okay, what does it drop?
What is this?
Oh, nice.
A crawler core.
Okay, maybe if I scan here...
Guys, I don't think there's crystals at a base, guys.
I don't...
I don't think... I don't think there's crystals...
Oh, jeez!
Oh, god, it's green!
It's green!
Okay, I did it.
Okay.
Okay, I was a little worried because it was green.
I thought green means it's gonna be stronger.
I was a little worried.
I don't think there's crystals here, guys.
I don't...
I don't think there's crystals here.
I...
I have eight minutes left.
Thank you.
Thank you, Real Alpha.
But I really...
I really need to find this one crystal.
Oh my god!
Fucking finals!
And it starts raining!
This is...
When would my luck...
When would my luck change?
And it starts raining.
Okay.
You know what?
Fuck me, I guess.
I didn't like rain.
No, lord.
Only crystals.
Alright.
Here we go.
I found the last... the last remaining crystal that people have not scavenged yet.
I swear to god, if I get there and another player took...
What the fuck?
Wait, is he?
Oh, no.
Oh, I have zero ammo, guys.
Oh, this is very bad.
This is actually... Oh, this is actually very bad for me.
Oh, JK.
JK.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Is he dead?
Okay.
Thank god.
I was... I was scared.
Guys, I was very scared.
I had no ammo.
Okay.
We got it.
We fucking finally...
Went and dealt melee.
The last fucking crystal in the world.
There's no way I needed more crystals.
There's no fucking way.
Oh, my god.
Just at 5,000, too.
Okay, we're gonna head to the elevator.
Alright.
Elevator time.
How far is it?
Oh, god.
It's pretty far.
Okay.
We're gonna go this way.
It overheats really fast, so I need to, like, balance my... my run.
No, please.
No.
Please.
Oh, he's in the water.
He can't get out of the water.
That's good.
I need to, like, manage my run.
It's okay.
I'm gonna make it.
There's no way.
Okay.
Ascend.
They can't climb.
They don't have opposable thumbs.
That's fucking right.
I know they don't have opposable thumbs.
Okay.
I'm, like, balancing my run ability now.
No, it's blocking me from the elevator.
Please.
I have zero ammo.
Zoom.
No, there's two of them.
No, I overheated!
It's okay.
They don't see me.
Their AI can't see me.
Guys, it's okay.
Their pathway's not gonna hit me all the way here.
Yeah, see?
It gave up.
It had to run a little bit more and it gave up.
Thank fucking god.
Zero ammo but two big arms.
Oh my god, please.
We're almost there.
We're so close.
Oh, why is there so many of you?
You can keep going.
Just make sure you have enough battery to return.
Don't worry.
I do.
Did I, like, fucking go the longest way possible?
Like...
No.
No!
Please!
I worked so hard to be here!
Oh god.
Heal me.
No.
Does he see me?
Guys, I think I chose, like, the longest area to be in.
Like...
Like, really?
Oh my god.
And it starts raining.
Okay.
Okay, 300 meters.
We're so close.
I know it's raining but I know I'm in choice.
Oh god.
They're almost there.
This has to be the roughest journey of my life.
Alright.
We don't...
Oh no, here you go.
Return.
Please.
Oh my god.
The Sia.
What about the Sia?
Weather resistance depleted.
Please.
Further weather and contamination damage will...
Please!
No!
My HP is raining!
Fifteen seconds until elevator evolves.
Fifteen seconds, please!
I'm dying out here!
That's okay.
I can live fifteen seconds.
This has been very rough on me.
Real alpha.
Does that...
Five seconds.
No, it's okay.
I'll be fine.
The elevator is...
I'm not gonna... It's okay.
A little acid rain is not gonna hurt anybody, right?
See, we made it.
Elevator will descend in fifteen seconds.
Please, I swear to god.
We're good people.
Analysis complete.
Holy fuck.
That scared the shit out of me.
No violence.
Please, I'm unarmed.
I'm...
Good timing.
I thought I was actually dead at the time.
Just kidding.
Oh my god.
We got lucky out there.
The timing.
Let's hope we didn't use it all up.
All right.
How about we go over...
Oh my god.
That was actually...
Look at me go.
You can see me fucking...
We engaged in battle and defeated the enemy.
You can see me walk around in a circle trying to figure out where the crystal is.
I was so confused.
I was so fucking confused.
We engaged in battle and defeated the enemy.
All right.
Nice.
Where the fuck is...
Oh my god.
There were so many players around me.
We engaged in battle and defeated the enemy.
We did it.
There's Odin Lover right here.
Encountered a chaser at this location.
Yeah, but chasers are so weak.
It's not even...
Successfully escaped.
It's not even that scary.
The rain clouds cleared up...
I didn't realize... This map is actually a lot bigger than I expected.
Encountered an ender...
Everyone's avoiding me.
We engaged in battle and defeated the enemy.
This is where I'm like...
Guys, it's because of all of you guys, I couldn't find a fucking crystal.
You mind it all.
Like...
The rain clouds cleared up here.
All right.
Then I got another tool here.
This is a 19-minute report?
How fucked...
How confused was I?
How is this a 19-minute report?
I was so confused.
No,
I don't...
I just think it's so funny.
Okay.
Oh my God.
I was so...
What the fuck?
Wait.
No, I...
No, I have to go back after that.
Like, what the fuck happened there?
Like, I traveled so far.
Like...
Like, like how...
Oh my God.
I was so confused.
Like, I was actually...
I was so...
I went everywhere.
I was...
I was everywhere.
I was so fucking confused.
The entire world tour.
I like...
I traveled across the world.
I truly lost child.
I did not expect myself to like be that confused.
If you PVP you couldn't...
Guys, this is my first mission.
I'm not winning any PVP battles.
I'm not winning any.
I'm going on my own journey to the west.
My channel is still here.
Not a bad haul.
Oh my God.
Where was I?
Where the fuck was I?
I went to a new area.
Where the fuck...
Why was there so many people here?
Why was that so...
Why did I not bump into any of these people?
There were four different people here?
Why did I miss all of them?
And then there's that guy.
Oh, and then I met that guy.
He went and won.
Why did I miss those guys?
Guys!
Holy shit!
You're not invited to the meeting.
Alright, nice.
Yeah.
Anyway guys, there is PvP.
There is PvP in this game.
I was just very scared about PvP.
Alright.
Oh!
I made so much money!
What a journey.
I literally explored so much.
Trying to find these goddamn crystals.
Oh my god, I'm rich!
I have a hand grenade?
I have like crafting stuff?
Alright, proceed.
Okay, I got it.
I brought like five or some shit.
I did that!
I did real alpha!
Oh my god, now I can spend my money!
They weren't on the map yet.
The game seems to start tracking people who are on the map at the end.
Even though they might join halfway through.
Oh, that's interesting.
Ninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god!
I'm marketable!
We need resources.
Once we've got that secured, we can revamp our production space.
If we fix up the floor and do something about the walls, we can make a craft station in here.
Oh, that's true!
Wait, so I don't get auto-repaired afterwards?
Okay, make sure to report back after...
Oh, I need to collect a completion request, please.
Yeah!
I can make my house prettier!
So my robot anime waifu would love me more.
Nice.
Stay sharp and prepare for the next one.
Yeah!
Put your adult pants on.
Time to learn about job requests.
There's more?
Time for a little lesson about requests.
Go forth and complete these requests.
Oh, she's like a little Navi.
I just realized that.
You'll get access to new products at the store.
New crafting recipes.
Yeah!
You'll also be allowed to sortie into more regions.
I get to go to the west.
The more you'll have available to you.
Or the south, sorry.
So remember, helping others helps you.
She's like Navi but hotter.
Because she's not a fucking circle.
She's not a circle anymore.
Okay, upgrade my...
Upgrade your craft station.
I mean...
Oh, I automatically accepted it.
Okay.
Is she doing my dishes?
Like...
Okay.
Okay, production.
Okay, to really put...
Yeah, Navi wouldn't do my dishes.
I hate to really think...
To really put your garage to use.
Try repairing the walls, ceilings, and floor.
Register items you need for renovations to your wish list.
Your magus will remember them and offer you relevant advice while out on expeditions.
Oh, so like...
So tell me what I need to...
To like...
To renovate.
Okay.
What would it look like?
What would it look like if I quick build?
Like...
Do I just...
I don't want to spend anything.
I'm worried that it's going to make me spend stuff when I do quick build.
Okay, complete.
Does it look better?
Does it actually look better?
Did she just snap her fingers and it's just going to be better now?
Okay.
What do you think?
What the fuck did she do?
And I think that should do it.
Like, there's still stuff on the floor.
Like, what did you do?
Like, there's still garbage on the floor.
What did you do?
It looks worse?
Like, I can't tell.
Like, there's still...
Why is there dirt on the floor?
Why is there...
Floor!
There's grass on the floor!
How did you have this grass on the...
There's fucking...
An environment.
There's fucking terrarium.
There's...
An entire ecosystem is growing on my floor.
How is that helpful?
I don't understand.
Oh, yeah.
This money.
I'm not spending money.
We're waiting.
Wait.
What is in the corner now?
There are no brooms.
Okay.
What is she going to do here?
Yeah, we need to make a craft station.
The alpha cleans your mecha and makes your floor worse.
Imagine.
What the beta would do.
All right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Pretty sure those weeds are...
That's not what weeds are.
What do you...
Weeds are not supposed to be edible.
What are you trying to do to me?
Okay.
That looks a little better.
Not the ceiling.
Did he...
Is she trying to make me eat weeds?
Guys, I think I chose the wrong one.
The wrong...
I'm mad at you, bro.
Okay.
There's less...
All right.
That's better.
There's less of a fucking ecosystem.
But, like, how is this a max level?
Guys, I don't understand how a hole in my ceiling is the max level.
But...
All right.
Poster girl.
Exactly.
Thank you.
The girl on the cover wouldn't do this to me.
All right.
Let's see.
Set up a craft station.
Okay.
All right.
Eat the weed, Doki.
Complete.
What do I have?
Time to put in the craft station.
Come on.
Let's get to it.
Yeah!
The craft station.
All right.
I just wonder if I'm just sitting there watching her do all of this.
Like, I'm complaining, but, like, I won't do anything to help her out.
God, I'm perfect.
Don't mock the ventilation system.
Miracle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm just getting into the immersion, guys.
Oh, that's a lot better.
Okay.
I just want to get she can do all of that, guys.
Oh, my God.
She can, like...
She's like an engineer.
She can do everything.
Oh my God.
Oh, my God.
Looks so much better now.
It looks so nice.
I wish I...
I wonder if I could visit other people's houses.
And craft equipment and consumables as well as make repairs.
As you venture to a more challenging location, upgrading your equipment is a must.
Okay.
Wait, I need a repair.
Can I repair?
That's for sure.
Like, I am...
Did I repair?
I guess I repaired everything.
Can I... weapons.
Can I upgrade my weapon?
Oh!
This is just repairing everything.
I want to craft.
Oh, I didn't repair all!
Okay.
Wait, how do I repair all?
How do I repair all though?
Uh...
No, I want to repair all.
How do I do it?
All items?
Oh, there it is!
6,800 and...
Guys, I don't...
Guys...
We don't need repairs.
We...
Oh, wait.
Oh, it cost 2?
Why did it say 6,890?
Oh!
It means it uses... Oh!
Sorry, I can't math.
Sorry.
Guys, I can't math.
I think you guys know that.
Can I make anything cool?
No, I cannot.
Okay.
I need aluminum scrap and first gen.
Oh, these are heals!
I can't afford that.
I haven't been...
I haven't been like scrounging for stuff.
Are these all my materials?
I guess they are.
What do you mean cleaning?
Am I gonna make her clean?
Like, what is this?
What do you mean like...
What do you mean like cleaning?
Okay, I surrender.
Surrender?
Okay, I want...
What do I have?
Okay, we gotta have this so we make sure nobody tries to kill us.
Okay, Roger.
Okay, there we go.
We need...
We need this.
Wait, she takes a bath?
Wait, at what point do I unlock that?
Like, what?
Okay.
What?
Wait, excuse me?
Okay.
I got money.
Excuse me?
She takes a bath?
Okay.
I think we're fine.
Prep.
220.
What is this?
Hand grenade.
Repair kits.
Okay, we need ammo.
I just realized I have...
Wait, what happened to my inventory?
What the fuck happened to my inventory?
What?
Wait, did I...
Did I accidentally...
What happened?
Oh, I cleared all?
How the fuck did I...
How did I...
Oh, how did I do that?
Press M?
Oh.
Okay, nice.
What is this?
Light energy...
Oh, okay, nice.
We'll grab more light ammo.
Because I feel like I...
Actually, no.
I need to make sure I don't use all my...
Uh, alright.
I think we're good.
I think we're good to go.
Uh, alright.
Let's see.
I'm ready.
Okay, at one point...
Um, do I...
Guys, at one point...
All I'm saying...
Is do I unlock the cleaning?
So, I'll be right back.
I'm gonna grab more water.
I'll be right back.
Guys, I don't have insurance.
I need to remind you guys.
I do not have insurance.
Please.
I can't afford...
Insurance right now, bro.
Guys, please.
I have a robot.
And I have a waifu...
To take care of.
Guys, please.
I...
Wait,
the insurance...
Is free?
I...
I'm sorry.
I live in North America.
I never realized insurance...
Is free.
Insurance can be free?
When was that?
What the fuck is...
There's no way.
How would the insurance company...
Make thousands, millions of dollars...
Off of people?
Okay, let's get this crystal.
Yay!
Guys.
In Canada...
Even though health insurance...
Is free...
You gotta wait 2 million hours...
Until like you get...
You get to see a doctor.
So...
Like...
You guys don't understand.
Free healthcare...
Is not as great as you think it is.
Like...
We've got contact from another doctor.
It's not...
It's not as like...
The perfect world.
If you got stabbed...
And you have free insurance...
You're still waiting...
Like 2 million hours, guys.
If it's not a...
If it's not like an emergency stab.
If it stabbed you in a place...
Where it's like...
As long as you won't bleed out...
And it's not in your internal organs...
Then it's fine.
And so like...
They're not gonna see you.
If you have free insurance.
Wait.
Where's the monster?
It's still free though.
Oh, chaser.
That's what we have to kill.
Okay, nice.
Oh, we got you.
A chaser?
Oh, he's dead.
Just don't get stabbed.
Easy.
The only difference is that...
For Americans, you guys still have to wait...
2 million hours.
To be paid.
Yeah, you guys have to think.
You guys have to pay.
And still wait the same amount.
We get it for free.
But we still have to wait a long time.
We gotta pay more.
We won't wait less.
Okay.
Alright.
Hello, George.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where the fuck are they?
I found 200 monsters.
But now I find 2 million crystals?
What is this?
Now I can't find...
A single monster.
Okay.
An incoming...
What?
What did I detect?
Guys.
Okay.
I need to know.
Guys.
Nobody has explained to me...
When do I unlock...
Cleaning.
Nobody has yet...
Said anything about that.
From a new what?
Oh, Cradle is a robot.
Oh, am I getting stalked?
Am I getting stalked?
Who's fucking stalking me?
Like...
Who's stalking me?
Okay.
I can't find a single monster.
It's like they know.
Mobility has decreased.
It's like they know that I need like...
I need to kill monsters.
I detect a faint sound of an engine somewhere.
Oh, thank fucking god.
Okay.
There is a...
There is the monster.
This is the target of the hunt request.
Can you upgrade the base to get a fucking...
Bathtub?
Oh no, please.
Why is it raining?
Ender has sustained damage.
Is he dead yet?
Why is he just standing there?
Okay, nice.
Alright, we gotta go inside.
Wait, is that a bad guy?
It's a bad guy.
That is absolutely a bad guy.
Oh my god, that is a bad guy.
Wait, where is he?
That's fine, he's dead.
Oh, there's so much loot here!
Nice!
Okay, we got a lot of good loot though.
A lot of upgradeable loot.
Wait, what's this?
Who needs...
Oh no, Jonesy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, that's money!
Okay, we gotta wait here until it stops raining.
Is it still...
God damn it, it's still raining.
Okay.
I'm reloading.
Guys, please.
Guys, when you fix the environment, I can't...
I can't deal with this rain, guys.
I can't deal with the rain every...
every 10 seconds, guys.
Please.
I just passed the target?
Ooh, loot though.
There's one here.
Isn't that just Canada?
Yeah.
That's the West Coast for you.
That's the worst part about living in the West Coast.
We don't get snow.
We just get rain.
We literally just get rain.
That's it.
Alright.
Let's see.
We need two more.
I heard him.
I heard a guy.
Oh, there he is.
There's one.
There's one more.
Snow is fun.
I hate the snow.
Honestly, like...
If I had to choose between snow or rain, I'd choose rain.
Just because snow is such a bitch in general when it comes to like...
When it comes to like having a dog.
At least a dog would...
His dad would still like go use the bathroom.
But like, when it's snowing, he refuses.
He fucking refuses.
Oh, thank god.
That's a large...
Oh no, it's a small one.
Okay, we'll go for that.
Alright, that's the last one.
Oh my god, this was easier than the crystal.
I didn't go on a fucking adventure like last time.
Thank god.
Bye.
Alright, he's almost dead.
Okay, nice.
We did it.
Where's the closest?
What's this?
Oh my god, remember when I went all the way here?
When there was like two near me?
I can't believe I went that way.
Oh my god.
Oh hey, there's more here.
Oh, I need green barrels.
Okay.
I need to find more of that.
Is this just like in the wild?
Yeah, tiny dogs don't like snow because it's like bad because their legs are too tiny so it touches the floor.
So their stomach touches the floor so they fucking hate that shit.
Oh my god.
I need to find...
Guys, is there any dragoons in my world right now?
Can you drop me like five green barrels?
I don't know where to find them.
Where do I find the green barrels?
That's an engine.
That's an engine?
Guys, I don't know where to find this.
I'm so bad.
I'm so bad at exploring.
How do I get up top?
What the fuck?
I'm like stuck down here.
Oh, it's a bandit.
Maybe he has them.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, he's doing so much damage!
I'm sorry!
Help!
That's right.
What you gonna do?
Walk up to me in my heels?
Wait, where did he go?
Did he die?
Oh.
Oh no, he reset itself.
Wait, why the fuck did you reset yourself?
What are you doing?
Wait, where did he go?
My...
Oh, we're going like merry-go-round right now.
Oh no.
Please leave me alone.
Are you serious?
How strong are you?
Oh, he's dead.
Okay.
Okay, he was that strong.
Is there any green barrels?
Okay, no.
That's just normal stuff.
Oh no, I don't have enough inventory space.
Okay.
Okay, I can keep taking stuff.
That should be fine.
Yeah, 99?
That's fine.
Oh, overloaded.
Oh, but they're good stuff.
They're good stuff.
No!
I don't have green barrels!
Okay, I guess we just go.
We just leave.
Okay, we have to find a way to go up.
Is it up here?
How the fuck do I go up?
I have to go upstairs.
I can't read maps.
Are you fucking...
Okay, I need to go this way.
Alright, this is it.
Guys, are you...
Guys, please.
Guys, if you're in my map area, please, I need green barrels.
That's all I want.
I need green barrels.
Am I going the right way?
Oh wait, it's this way.
I can read a map, guys.
Drop the trash.
Oh, there it is!
I see the elevator!
Nice.
Alright, we did it.
We found our way.
I can't.
I can't find the last two green barrels.
I only need green barrels.
Well, I'm like full HP, technically.
I just want upgrades so I can unlock a very special thing.
I'm not going to end stream until I unlock it.
This is like my goal.
This is my goal in life.
That is actually my only goal in life right now for this game.
I didn't bump into anybody.
I guess like nobody really PVPs because they don't want to get banned from the association.
Wait, is this a guy?
Hey!
Please.
I am unarmed.
That gun is just cosmetics.
Guys.
I'm unarmed.
This gun is just cosmetics.
I swear to God.
I swear.
Alright, nice.
I should be fine.
Nobody here.
A return request?
What?
Oh, that means they're leaving on a different area.
It's just...
It's my cosplay.
It's my cosplay gun.
We did it!
I wonder if there will be teams in the future for this game.
Did I make money?
How much money did I make?
Alright.
Oh, there's the guy I met!
We found somebody.
That's the guy I met!
Oh, he has the anime husband!
We were literally like side by side.
Did not see him at all until we fucking...
I saw him like 30-50 meters away in the distance.
We engaged in battle and defeated the enemy.
That's us.
Who the fuck is this guy?
Oh, is he fighting a boss there?
Who's that guy?
Oh, is he a bounty?
Is that why there's red there?
I don't understand what the red is.
Rain confirmed here.
A light shower.
More entered the fray and things escalated to a multi-cradle fight.
Oh, there was a hunter here?
Here's where we obtained crafting materials.
Wait, was he a real guy?
Wait, was he a...
Wait, who the fuck was that guy?
Wait, was he a real guy?
Who's that?
Oh, he wasn't.
Okay, I was like...
Oh, that's an NPC.
Okay, thank god.
I was like, there's no way.
Why did he look like that?
Why can't my anime waifu look like that?
We engaged in battle and defeated the enemy.
This is where we obtained a requested item.
Never seen this item in this location before.
Logging coordinates for reference.
We encountered a crawler Where was I?
How did I get here?
How the fuck?
How the fuck did I get here?
Oh, and I walked back.
Okay, I was gonna say.
I went that far?
What?
Okay, this is...
Oh, this is another bandit that I killed.
Yeah, I got another bandit here.
And I just walked backwards.
And then...
I saw him again!
This is where I saw that guy again.
Alright, exit.
Oh my god, I just went like...
Let's start by reviewing your AO Crystal Hall.
Alright.
Yay!
We're gonna be rich!
Real alpha!
I'm gonna... I'm gonna spoil you!
Looks like you got some valuable items.
Oh, I did.
I got a lot of shit.
Wait, is race... Oh, it's materials.
Okay.
And now, let's take a look at the request progress you've made.
Okay, that is my bad.
I... I could not find more green barrels.
I have no idea where the fuck to find these.
Be sure to apply.
I tried my best, ma'am.
I don't know where to find green barrels.
I don't know this map good enough.
There was no dragoons in my lobby, so I couldn't... I couldn't mooch off of other dragoons.
Alright.
Completion!
By the way, I heard there's short staff at the lab.
Maybe you can see if there's anything you could help out with.
I need to go to the foresty money...
area.
I got arms!
I got cosmetic arms.
I have crafting stuff.
New request has been made.
What did they give me?
Use the following amount of mag... Oh, this one!
Buy the following amount.
Defeat the following amount of enders with an assault rifle.
Defeat the following amount...
Oh, okay.
So...
Do I need to repair anything?
Okay.
Repair.
Alright.
So I need a craft.
Is this a sub machine?
Oh.
I don't have the B grade sub machine part.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, wait.
What does the arms do?
Oh!
It's makes it... What does it do?
It makes it stronger!
Okay, I see.
That's what it does.
Okay, I still need...
I need one more!
Can I buy that?
I wonder if I... Is there a shop?
That I can buy that from?
No.
I can only craft.
There's no...
Wait!
There has to be!
Yeah!
There's an item shop!
Do I have enough?
No, it doesn't matter.
I need to actually...
Wait, can I just buy the sub machine?
Do I need a craft?
Oh, I need to craft it!
Oh!
But, um...
It says that I need a... It says I need to like buy... I need to craft the barrels.
Don't I?
Does buying it count?
I wonder if it counts.
I'll just buy one.
Okay, I'll buy five.
I have enough money.
Can I do it?
Yes, you fucking liars.
It still says craft.
I need to buy...
You meant the machine.
Oh my god.
You were talking about the fucking machine gun.
Okay.
Let's buy it.
Okay, I bought it.
I thought you meant...
Okay.
Probably the following.
The fee.
Okay.
There we go.
I thought you guys...
I thought you guys meant the machine gun.
The fucking... Oh my god.
Okay, how do I find...
Okay.
Prep.
Where's my other arm?
There we go.
We're gonna...
Change it to... Oh, wait.
No.
We'll change this.
Okay.
She's so good at reading.
What do I have to press?
M, right?
M.
Okay.
Automatic.
Yeah.
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back, guys.
Back, guys.
I'm back.
Alright.
What do I have to do?
When do I... Please.
When do I unlock this?
Oh my god.
Okay.
No, we can do... Is it living space?
Yes.
What is it?
Is it flooring?
Okay.
Maybe it's flooring.
It can't be.
It's not... Maybe it's flooring.
Guys, what do I...
What do I have to do to unlock living space?
Do we...
Okay.
We'll do floor space first.
I have to upgrade the bathroom?
How do I get the bathroom?
Okay.
We got the pit space.
We got the floor.
Alright.
My anime robot waifu.
Fix the floor for me while I watch.
We never had the bathroom in the first place?
Guys, I just want to unlock everything, you know?
We'll make sure that you guys see everything it gives us, you know?
Like, you guys get like a clear vision on what this game is about.
You know?
I'm just doing what...
I'm just trying to be a good um, chiller.
I'm just trying to chill really well and just give you guys everything!
I...
We'll be able to sort you much more safely with the options this way.
Oh, hey.
Actually, it's nicer now.
Let's turn to the ceiling walls.
How could you do that for the first place?
There was like dirt on the floor.
This one actually doesn't have dirt on the floor now.
Okay.
I need brittle iron ore infusion compound.
I don't know where the fuck I can get that.
Oh my god, please.
We're so close to getting living space.
Come on.
Please.
Okay.
I need to look at my quest.
We need...
Guys, I need you guys to remind me.
Okay.
We need to get green barrels.
We need a kill enders with the assault... the assault rifle.
The assault rifle... Do I have assault rifle?
And then we need to use...
AO searches and mag...
Okay.
We can do all of this at once.
Let me... Wait.
What do I have?
Do I have assault rifle on?
Is that...
That's not assault rifle.
Oh!
Okay.
Assault rifle.
We need more light ammo.
We actually need more light ammo.
Um... Okay.
We got...
We got this.
This is fine.
Okay.
Sort.
There's more?
Guys, okay.
I'm gonna put insurance in there.
Okay.
And we can...
in the gun.
I didn't even know that the gun wouldn't hit the gun.
Okay.
Now...
We got one.
How do I run away if they have the same speed as me?
Why do I look like PlayStation 1 and he looks like PlayStation 5?!
Like, that's so messed up!
Okay, how do I...
Um...
Wait, how do I put you in insurance?
Guys, I wanna...
Okay...
Can I apply all insurance?
Wait, no, that... I need money for that.
Wait, that costs money.
No, I don't...
No.
Okay, guys, we're not gonna have insurance, guys.
See?
Yeah, but it says a thousand!
Guys!
135!
Guys, I'm not... that's a lot!
I can't...
It's 135 dollars!
Guys, inflation-wise, that's like...
Inflation-wise, that's like...
That's like a million dollars, okay?
Initial line of two magnets were...
Okay.
We don't need lore.
If you wanna know what robot inflation is like...
Look up robot inflation on Google.
Okay.
Hey, there's crystals!
There's so much crystals!
Wait, these are like the guys I have to kill, right?
Dragoon insurance contribution tablet!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Jesus, the recoil for this is crazy!
Okay, nice.
Oh, this is good for fusion combat!
We need this!
We actually needed this!
Alright, nice.
You wanna look...
Look at how inflation rates are like.
Remember to look up robot inflation.
Nice.
Okay, we got another chaser.
Oh, you found one?
Wait, did somebody took the green bear?
Oh, there it is!
There's a green bear!
Oh, thank god!
Thank you!
You're so useful!
Okay, what the fuck?
How did he get here?
Please, I can't...
Oh god, please.
Oh no, I don't have enough.
Wait, when...
When does it show up?
When do you start...
Oh, it's loading!
Okay.
Did it stop raining yet?
No.
Okay, I have two...
Oh, there's two barrels here!
Oh no.
I can't...
Guys, I can't!
I have to use her ability!
For restoring field!
Guys, it's okay.
There's no way I'll die.
Guys, there's no way.
There's no possible way I could die, guys.
There's...
No way.
I can't be that unlucky, guys.
Like...
Guys, we have to use our abilities for the objective, guys.
There's no way.
There's no way I could die.
We don't need it.
We'll be...
We're so healthy.
We're so healthy, guys.
Oh my god.
Please, save the environment.
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Oh, yeah!
Just looks at me and walks away!
Where are they fighting?
Oh, they're friends!
Wait, how did you guys fight each other?
I'm by myself!
How do you guys have friends?
How did he find friends?
Wait, what?
I just said, stop fear.
How did he get friends?
I don't understand.
Yes, I'm saying to play with other people.
Did it stop raining?
How is it still?
Please, it's right there.
I just want the green barrels.
It's literally right there.
Please.
Oh my god.
Why is it still raining?
Why?
No, it didn't.
Look.
Look, I'm literally taking damage.
Okay, now it hasn't.
I can't believe you guys...
I can't believe that one guy baited me.
He was like, no, it stopped raining.
Look.
God damn it.
Okay.
How many more do I have to do here?
I need to find more enders.
Oh wait, there you go.
We found one.
That's good.
Dude, lost like five shields.
Look, five...
I still lost!
Okay,
we gotta kill this guy.
I need him to get closer to me so I can...
Can you look at me?
Oh my god, please.
Nice.
Okay, that is...
How much more do I need?
Oh, he doesn't say.
Wait, where?
Oh, this guy!
Okay, I need a...
How do I look up my objectives?
Uh...
Wait, does it tell you how to look up my objectives?
I don't know, actually.
Oh my god, I almost have...
Is it open the map?
Oh!
Okay, I need some machine guns.
Okay, this one.
I need to use this one then.
Oh my god, I got the...
See, I told you guys!
I can use the ability!
Nice.
Okay, we did it.
We used one.
Okay, and then we need...
We need one more green barrel.
And then we need...
To use our thingy two more times.
And then we should be good.
Okay.
Oh, hey!
Hey, are you friendly?
Hey!
Is that...
Is that a robot husband you got there?
Oh, hey there!
Wait, is this a bandit?
Why is there a bandit here?
Like, why is there a bandit?
Why is there two bandits?
What have you been doing?
Why did you bring two bandits here?
Okay.
Okay, that one guy brought like two fucking bandits here.
It's crazy.
I hate your hat.
He ignored it.
He literally brought all of them here.
Hey there.
Hey.
He doesn't know.
He didn't know he got hit.
He didn't know.
He didn't...
Oh no, where is he coming?
He didn't know.
He actually...
He actually didn't notice at all.
They might attack.
They might not.
Commencing analysis.
Hey.
Are you friendly?
I'm sorry.
Hey.
Oh god, die!
Oh shit!
Oh my god, he's so friendly!
He's so...
He's taking...
Guys!
Oh my god, he's so funny!
Oh my shit!
That's so funny!
Please!
Oh please!
Please, I just want to...
Please, I...
Please!
My robot!
Commencing replay.
We've not been able to destroy this location.
We engaged in battle and defeated the enemy.
I knew!
Please, I just want to give her a bathroom!
Please, my wife needs a bathroom!
Please!
He needs a bathroom!
He needs a bathroom, guys!
I thought...
He shot me first!
I thought I was gonna die regardless!
We encountered bandits at this location.
Oh my god...
I thought I...
I already was like 30 HP!
There was nothing I could do!
I was already 30 HP!
Anton, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I bailed out.
I don't know what bailing out would do.
Honestly.
Like, do I just lose everything?
As for things lost, here's a readout.
Nooooooo!
Please, I read a lesson.
No need to feel down.
Use this as a springboard...
No need to feel down?!
Look at all the items I lost!
And now, let's take a look at...
What do you mean, no need?
I... God!
I was so close!
Our bathroom...
Our fucking... Please!
I just want the bathroom!
Please, guys!
I just...
You will lose all the items you're carrying.
The items that you wish to keep.
Be sure to put them in your safe pocket to keep them protected.
Even if you lose all your equipment, you can pick up starter arms for free.
If you want to get used to life as a drifter, it's probably best you only take starter equipment.
Oh my god.
I'm broke.
I hate this.
Wait, what?
Do I just need the...
Nooo!
I don't have the assault rifle!
I did!
I did pay 135!
Wait, what do I need?
No, I didn't finish the fucking assault machine gun!
I only had to buy this stupid fucking...
And I can't afford it!
I can't...
I can't afford it.
I literally just needed two more.
I needed two more kills!
I can't afford it!
I am...
so broke.
Please!
I just wanted to give her...
I just wanted to give her a fucking bathroom!
Okay.
I swear if I die again, we're just GG's.
I swear.
Okay.
I'm okay.
I don't need...
I did!
I even paid 135 dollars!
I...
I can't believe it!
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I have to fucking find two more barrels!
Okay.
I don't have enough for the fucking...
Let's see.
Gonna...
Oh!
He's in good standing!
I hope you get fucking...
Whoever killed me...
I hope you get bounty hunted by the rank one guy.
Hey.
Oh he seems friendly.
Okay.
Nice.
He's friendly.
Okay.
Thank god.
Thank... Thank fucking god.
Alright.
Okay.
We just gotta...
Wait.
AO Crystal?
Okay.
We'll get the crystal.
We might as well.
We need the crystal.
We need a fusion compound and the ore shit.
Wow.
If only I have the machine gun for this.
If only I have the machine gun.
No!
What?!
You're not dead?!
Oh wait.
This is a shotgun.
Wait.
This is good.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
This is our first time getting the shotgun.
I mean, shotgun is pretty good.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
That shit is...
That shit is a lot of damage.
Okay.
We got a crystal though.
We got a crystal.
Oh.
Thank god.
Okay.
Guys.
We don't need a heal.
We have...
We'll be fine.
We need to use our abilities.
Guys.
Okay.
Maybe if I can get up here.
I wanna get... They must have like good loot over here.
As long as there's nobody here to kill me, we'll be fine.
Or get up there.
Guys.
Combat unlikely.
We'll be fine.
There's no way it happens twice in a row.
Guys.
How the fuck do I get up there?
How do I get up?
Oh.
There's over here.
Okay.
It has to be material.
I'm so broke.
Guys.
I...
I need money.
Like I'm desperate here.
I'm at... I need...
I need to buy this stupid submachine gun.
Okay.
We have copy scrap.
Oh my god.
None of this.
I don't need any of this.
I need the fusion core and the iron ore.
And I need green barrels.
Oh my god.
I need to remember not to fall down.
I need to remember not to like fall down here.
Please.
I need money.
I need green barrels.
Where am I?
Please.
Where are the green barrels?
Where are the barrels?
Oh.
Repair kit.
There's loot here.
Oh.
Thank god.
Okay.
There's loot here.
Yeah.
But she... Do you see that green bar at the bottom?
We have to wait until that is like uh... full before I can use it.
Which sucks.
Please.
Guys.
Please stop taking all the green barrels.
Please.
I need to finish this one quest.
I've been holed isolated.
Please stop taking all the green barrels.
Guys.
That's all I asked for.
This is the hardest fucking material to find in this world.
Like I...
It's not even the crystal.
It's literally the green fucking barrel.
Oh my god.
Oh.
That's a lot of chasers.
If only I had the gun to do this.
But I guess not.
Guys.
Is there any green barrels?
Are there any dragoons that won't kill me that has green barrels?
Please.
I've been on three different missions out here.
I've been on three different missions.
Okay.
Bandit boss?
What do you mean bandit boss?
What the fuck do you mean?
Please.
I'm so... I'm so low.
I can't.
I can't deal with any of this.
Association member?
There's a barrel?
There's a fucking...
Oh.
Is that green barrel?
Oh my god.
We fucking did it.
We found a green barrel.
Holy shit.
We found...
We found Narnia.
Oh my god.
We did it.
There's another one.
Oh my god.
It's my birthday.
Holy shit.
It's my fucking birthday.
That should be it, right?
I got three.
How's... How am I missing one more?
Wait.
It wasn't...
Oh my god.
I'm missing one more.
I need one more green barrel.
Hold.
What's that?
Oh, okay.
That's the...
Okay.
Wow.
If only I have... If only I have the gun for this guy.
If only.
If only I have the right gun.
Oh my god.
Please.
I don't need any of this.
I need another green barrel.
Where the fuck?
Please.
Where's the last barrel?
Where the fuck is it?
Hey.
We're friendly?
Oh, thank god.
I'm so happy.
I can't deal with this right now.
Oh my god.
What's that?
No.
That's just the exit.
God damn it.
Oh, wait.
This guy has fusion core.
Wait.
I need this.
This guy has fusion core.
Nice.
Okay.
That's... Yeah.
Yeah.
I need like a core.
Oh my god.
Just one more.
I... I... I literally need just one more.
Hit confirmed.
Please.
I need one more.
You can't do this to me.
Why is this like the hardest thing to find?
Why is it... Wait.
Is that blue equals... No.
That's just... No.
You mean my map shows it.
It just shows like enemy.
No, it doesn't.
Are you lying?
Wait.
Where does it say it?
Where does that... Where?
No.
We're not coming back with... I swear to god.
We're gonna find...
Guys.
No.
These are... I can't do these objectives.
Wait.
There it is.
Oh my god.
The last one.
There it is.
Oh my god.
This is it.
This is the promised land.
Oh my god.
We fucking...
found the promised land.
Holy shit.
And then there's... There's a mud stone.
Oh my god.
And there's...
Look at all these rewards.
Oh.
Why does it rain when it rains?
Makes me so sad.
Okay.
We gotta leave.
The promised land.
Okay.
Where is the closest?
This is the closest.
Okay.
Oh my god.
This is it.
We just gotta go home.
We finally got our barrels.
It took 20 years.
We just need to heal one last time and we're fucking free.
Where?
I can't jump.
I'm overheated.
Okay.
How do I get there?
It's right here.
Okay.
We're so close.
We're so close to freedom.
The bath is within the reach.
The bathroom.
Please.
Why?
Okay.
Alright.
We're okay.
Oh my god.
It took 20 years.
The fable bathroom is so close, guys.
It's almost there.
I can taste it.
I just need to buy the stupid submachine gun again.
And then we can have the bathroom.
It's worth it.
It's gonna be worth it.
It's gonna be so worth it.
Oh the ability.
The ability right.
Alright.
We did it.
Now we...
Thank god.
Okay.
We fucking actually did it.
I almost forgot the one other ability.
I didn't want to do that again.
Okay.
And then we gotta craft the stupid barrel sh...
I swear to god.
Somebody shoots me.
I swear.
If anybody comes near me, I'm gonna shoot them.
I swear to god.
If you come near, I'm gonna fucking shoot you.
I can't do this again.
I...
I can't do this stupid barrel search again.
Alright.
I had my shotgun out.
I was ready.
I was fucking ready.
Alright.
Nice.
That's me trying to find this stupid fucking green barrel.
Oh my god!
How far was I?
No.
What the fuck?
How did I travel that far?
It always surprises me how far I traveled in general.
Let's start by reviewing your AO crystal home.
Let's cash out...
Zero.
I was gonna say, did I actually have like, okay, $800?
That's fine.
I'm fine with that.
I have rare materials.
That's fine.
Now let's take a look at the...
Oh thank god.
You've completed a request.
Oh thank you.
Thank you robot waifu.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
The quest will give me money.
Guys.
It's okay.
The quest will give me money and I should be able to afford it.
Looks like you've got the hang of going on expeditions.
Now here's what you do with the spoils.
Okay.
Time for a lesson about cradle equipment.
Hope you brought back some AO crystals from your latest sorting.
You can use those mountains of cash to buy some strong equipment.
Equipment here is sorted by grade.
Good weapons are strong.
Good cradles have fancy features.
As he looks very fancy.
So go on and grab some equipment first.
I used to have good equipment.
I used to have good equipment guys.
Thank you.
You're such a dear.
Did he just give me a t-shirt?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you fucking...
Okay.
That gives me 5000.
That's a lot better.
It's gonna be like...
There's no way.
There's no fucking way that all I got was a t-shirt.
There's no fucking way after all that work I did.
I just got a fucking t-shirt.
I couldn't believe it.
14 minutes?
Okay.
Let's...
It's fine.
I'm okay.
I got the...
Okay.
That's funny.
That t-shirt is...
Yeah.
Did I do it?
Nice.
Oh my.
That's quite lovely as well.
Shan, you have a favorite outfit.
But you do need to change your pace every once in a while.
You must find new clothes for your beautiful maggots to wear or else.
Alright.
Nice.
A new request has been completed.
Let's fucking go.
Okay.
Upgrade your treasury to level 1 or higher.
Do I have enough for that?
Use the EQS.
The following... Are you making...
Try selecting EQS when you see another cradle on which you will... Oh!
Okay.
I didn't know you could do that.
That's interesting.
Oh my god.
That's $15,000.
Wait!
It's $15...
It's worth it!
It's fucking... Okay.
Fuck yeah.
It's worth it.
Guys, I literally get...
I literally get $15,000.
Like, it adds up.
Okay.
Thank god.
It's $15,000.
Like, it makes up for the money.
Like, I was like...
Thank fucking god.
Okay.
10, 8, Of course there's...
Use the treasury?
Oh, my god!
I still can't fucking upgrade this.
I still can't...
Can I still... I need...
I need brittle iron ore and a fusion compound.
How the fuck do I find that?
Do I put that on my wishlist?
How do I put that on my wishlist?
I thought you could put stuff on your wish...
Oh!
Here you go.
Unable to... Oh!
There.
Alright, wishlist.
Okay, there we go.
Now she will...
Now she'll help me find this.
Oh my god, we're so close.
Please.
We're so close.
We're actually so close.
Okay, buy.
We gotta buy.
What do we have to buy again?
Oh my god, was it the assault rifle?
Was it... Oh, it's zero dollars!
Are you trying to... There's no way.
Wait, there's no way.
Okay.
Oh, submachine gun plus... Okay, submachine gun.
Okay, submachine gun.
Alright.
It's 4,000!
Wasn't this 11k before?
Okay, whatever.
I'm not gonna complain.
I'm not gonna... I'm not gonna... I'm not gonna complain.
It's 4,000 dollars now and that's... I could have done this mission a long time ago, but that's okay.
That's... That's okay.
That's alright.
That's... That's... That's okay.
Babe.
Let's see.
What else do I need to do?
Alright, we gotta get the crystals.
We gotta kill two Enders.
We gotta get the EQS.
We gotta get the treasury?
Nice to meet you.
I'm just running for possibly to help.
First, I'll have to check your garage so you have all the necessary.
Okay, we can't get the treasury because we don't have anything.
That's fine.
Okay, repair.
Nice.
Alright, let's go in!
This is it.
We're so ready.
Okay, insurance though.
Insurance.
I've... I've learned my lesson regarding insurance.
I've... I've learned my...
I forgot.
I forgot to replenish ammo.
I forgot to replenish ammo, guys.
Hey...
Don't worry.
You have me at your side.
Hey.
I forgot to...
I took the wrong ammo, guys.
I took the wrong ammo.
Okay, 40 bullets in the dream.
We can kill them in 40 bullets, it's fine.
It's fine.
We can do this in 40 bullets.
There's no way.
40 bullets, that's fine.
40 bullets.
We killed one.
We got one.
We got one, guys.
Maybe we'll find bullets!
You don't know that!
We could find bullets in the end!
It'll be possible.
We can do this, I believe.
We're gonna find bullets in the end.
Alright, nice.
We got the crystal, too.
Alright, Jesus Christ, why does it take you so long to excavate?
It's okay!
We'll find it!
Is that it?
Oh shit, high purity.
Wow.
Okay, we have two high qualities.
We need to find...
We need to find another guy.
So we have one gun.
Like, what's the worst that could happen?
We have one gun.
Okay, guys, that's okay.
That's...
Alright, there's another crystal here.
We're gonna do this.
If we kill the bandits, we'll get bullets.
The bandits drop bullets.
Guys, I figured it out.
If I kill the bandits, we'll get bullets, guys.
Guys, I'm so smart.
Okay, how do I get up there?
It's fine.
Guys, we'll just kill the bandits!
They can't kill me!
There's no way!
I've been gaming for so long for my anime wife!
Please.
Guys, it'll be so worth it.
Guys, I swear to God, it'll be so worth it.
I swear to God.
How the fuck do I get there?
Okay, it has to be, like, somewhere here.
Where is it?
Oh, is that it?
Why is it a target?
Oh, it's right here.
Okay.
What's that target over there?
Is that the ore?
Where I'm going, I'm trying to get the fucking pure crystal.
Wait, why is there a heart here?
Oh, it's the iron ore!
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
That was on our wish list.
We got our brittle ore.
Okay, we need, like...
We got brittle ore complete.
Oh, thank God.
We got the brittle ore shit.
Okay, we got...
There has to be another bandit somewhere.
There has to be bandits somewhere!
Alright.
Where?
Wait, where, where, where?
I need to look at him.
Where?
Where is he?
Where, where is he?
Oh, my God.
No!
Stop!
I need you to stop!
Please!
Please, I need you to stop!
No!
He left!
I can't believe he left.
I can't believe he fucking left.
I need him here.
Where?
Oh, that's not... Where?
Who's looking at me?
Where?
I literally...
Someone's watching me, but I don't know.
Okay, we need... Oh, my God.
We literally need one more.
No!
They took the crystal!
Okay.
This is quite the rare item.
What?
She literally said there's someone next to me.
But where?
Make a skill prime and ready to go.
Oh, it's over there.
Okay.
I can make this.
Woo!
Okay, nice.
Oh, thank God.
There's...
I detect the faint sound of an engine somewhere.
Where?
Please!
Where are you?
It's part of my mission to look at you.
Please let me look at you.
That's all I asked for.
Okay, I need to watch this.
There we go.
See?
No fall damage.
Okay, excavate.
Oh, my God.
Am I being stalked right now?
Am I fucking being stalked right now, guys?
Is that... Is that it?
Is that it?
Okay, please.
I literally need one person, guys.
I need one of you guys.
Oh, low purity AOE crystal.
Oh, no.
I already have that.
Is there any, like, wish list?
AOE crystal.
What do I need?
I need, like, core, right?
The fusion core.
Oh, my God, guys.
I swear to God.
I need...
Please.
I need one person to, like, exist in my lobby.
Like, that's really... That's all I need.
There's abandon!
Yes!
Oh, wait.
There's lose.
Okay.
We're fine.
We're okay.
Heal.
Is that it?
Did I get... No, I didn't get bullets.
Okay.
Alright.
As soon as it stops raining, guys.
As soon as it stops raining, we'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
How do I...
Okay.
It's fine.
We're just safe in our little hut.
Wait.
I'm still taking damage.
Keep your wits about you.
Please.
I just...
I just need a...
I need to kill this one abandon.
He must have light ammo.
Please.
I just...
I didn't look at one person.
Where are all the people in my life?
I just need to look at one person.
There has to be one person somewhere.
Did he kill the abandon?
Please.
Where is that one person?
Where is he?
Oh, my God.
I swear to God.
The things I do for my fucking hot anime robot wife.
Why is there rain?
Have you ever heard of acid rain?
Yeah, apparently this rain is so fucking acidic that it burns my armor.
So I'm just chilling here.
You can't, like, look up in the sky and just go, ahh.
Precipitation levels decreasing.
Oh, my God.
Someone saved the environment.
I detect the faint sound of an engine somewhere.
There's an engine somewhere.
AO Search.
AO Crystal detected.
Expect little in terms of size.
Oh, my God.
I hear him.
Why are you outside?
AO Search.
AO Crystal detected.
Expect little in terms of size.
No!
It's still raining and thundering!
Oh, thank God.
There.
It should be over now.
It should be fucking over now.
But it's gotten better.
Okay.
What the fuck is that sound?
It's locked.
And without a code, there's no getting in.
Wait.
Oh, Blue Barrel.
Why is there so many dead people here?
What is this?
C-Grade?
Should I keep anything here?
Wait, that's pretty good.
No, I've overloaded.
Did somebody die here?
Like, why is there such good loot here?
Are people killing people?
I should leave.
I'm way over my head here.
I...
Wait, the elevator is closed!
Oh, my God!
Okay, we should leave.
We should...
We should leave.
I...
I realized, like...
I realized these are dead people.
Yeah.
I realized...
I realized those are...
other dead...
Oh!
Okay.
We've got contact from another Drifter.
This one's in good standing with the Association.
Did I do it?
Cargo details coming up.
No!
Get over here!
Wait!
I didn't do these twice correctly!
I didn't...
I didn't do these twice!
Come over here!
Come back!
This package was left behind by another Drifter.
I didn't do these twice!
Come back!
Come back here!
I didn't...
Please, I'm not stalking you.
I just...
Okay, okay.
I did it.
I did it correctly.
Okay.
I did it correctly, guys.
I...
It's gonna be like, why is she chasing after me?
Please, I didn't do it correctly.
I'm sorry.
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
We can drive back now.
Guys, I wasn't stalking him!
I needed to do my one mission!
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
We don't need to do that one mission.
I'm trying my best!
I'm just super slow!
I...
You think I don't wanna leave?
Like...
I'm just so slow.
I...
No!
I have too much loot!
All right.
Nice.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, God.
Okay, nice.
I swear to God.
Please.
We're okay, right?
We're...
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Now we're in good standing.
That's a cautionary association member.
They might attack.
They might not.
Commencing analysis.
Guys, this is not fair!
Guys...
Are we...
Are we good?
Please?
Are we okay?
PLEASE!
PLEASE DON'T ATTACK ME!
Please don't attack me.
I'm going around you so you can't aim.
I...
Stop being weird.
I thought he was gonna fucking... I need to go around him so he couldn't shoot me.
I need...
It said 47%.
It was... I was scared.
Commencing replay.
It was 47% chat.
I thought he was gonna fucking shoot me.
Like, why was it 47?
Let's start by reviewing your videos.
Why are you circling him?
So like, if he tries... if he thinks about shooting...
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm fucking rich.
So like, it's harder for him to shoot me because I'm circling him.
That's how it goes.
It's hard.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god, I completed so many requests.
He said he may shoot you, he may not!
He's like, he may shoot you, he may not!
And I don't wanna risk the me!
Alright, nice.
Oh my god, so much money now.
Yay!
Okay, wait.
I DID DO IT THREE TIMES!
I didn't read the fucking fine print.
I couldn't...
I didn't read the fine print.
God fucking...
Okay.
I never read the fine print apparently.
I couldn't scan 200.
I...
I didn't read the goddamn fine print.
I never read the fucking fine print.
I always forget to read.
Okay.
Wait, can I...
God...
God damn it.
Okay.
I'll upgrade.
This game is going to be the end of Toki.
I could have scanned him!
Do I have the bathroom yet?
Okay.
Let's get rid of these weeds first, yes?
Once we do, this will be a great space for us.
Just needs a little sprucing up, shall we say.
It'll be worth it, guys.
I swear to God, it'll be so worth it.
I swear to God.
I swear to...
You know, like, I was supposed to end after an hour.
The hard days were finished.
You guys see how I'm supposed to end after an hour?
You don't understand.
I need a bathroom.
I know it may not be ideal but we must be conscious that we spend our funds.
Are we eating the weeds right now?
I'll even throw in some of the homegrown mushrooms.
So be careful.
Be a good drifter and eat up.
I need protein!
Ma'am!
Wife!
I can't just eat mushrooms all the time!
Like, I need protein!
Do I not have a fusion cut?
Fucking...
Oh my god!
Okay.
Okay, guys.
I figured it out.
Alright.
Okay, we gotta collect.
Okay.
Oh, I can grow!
And I can grow resources later!
Okay, prep.
We need...
Alright, now we should have energy ammo.
Now...
Now... Now it should be okay.
Okay, we gotta get rid of this and then grab more of this.
Okay.
This should be fine.
We're fine.
We're okay now.
Everything is fine.
Everything is okay.
Is this common?
Uncommon, right?
Okay, and then we need...
We need to... Uncommon.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta get rid of ammo we don't really need.
So we can get rid of this.
And this.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's gonna be okay.
Everything will be okay.
Alright, and then...
Please, I... We're so close, guys.
We're...
We're so close, guys.
We're so close to what we need.
We...
We're... Please...
We're almost there.
We're... Guys, I swear to God.
We're so close.
Can you just...
Maybe this is it.
We can do this.
This has to be the last mission to get what we want.
This has to be.
Why did they kept the lock so far ahead?
Why?
This is it, guys.
This is it.
This has to be it, guys.
No way.
Okay.
We gotta get...
We gotta scan.
And then we...
We have our fucking energy gun now.
So...
So we'll be okay.
This can't damage me too bad, right?
Oh God, thank God.
Okay, there's a...
Okay, we don't need...
We don't need crystal.
Guys, we don't need crystals at all.
Okay, nice.
We just need materials.
We literally just...
We just need materials, guys.
We...
We don't need...
We need materials to upgrade our area.
We don't need crystals.
We have enough money.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Guys, we have materials.
Oh my God.
Thank God.
We got...
We got the fusion compound.
Oh my God.
Things are going okay for us right now.
Things...
Things are...
Things are already going okay.
I can't believe it.
Okay, nice.
We need crafting materials.
Wait, there is a guy right here.
Wait, somebody already used...
Got the crystal here.
Wait, these guys...
These guys drop materials.
No, they don't.
Okay, nice.
We have...
Okay, I have to keep thinking that is like...
Oh my God.
Oh, there's another chest.
Thank God.
I'll take it.
Okay, nice.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, they are grenades.
We don't need that.
Oh my God.
We are so close.
I can feel the bathroom.
I can use...
I'll be able to use the bathroom soon, chat.
What?
What's going to be today?
It's going to be this run.
This is it.
This is going to be it, guys.
I can almost smell the run right now.
I'm right here!
Oh god.
Please.
I don't need crystals, guys.
I just...
I just need...
I just need my materials.
Please, I just need my materials.
Where are any of the materials?
Oh my god.
Alright, we go up.
If we go up, there has to be ores.
There has to be ores right here.
There has to be.
Guys, where can I...
Where can I grab my upgrade items, guys?
That's really all I need.
I need more upgrade items.
Okay.
On the ground.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I just found out.
I can't even grab items on the ground.
Guys, where are the people?
Where are the other mechs?
Where the fuck are they at?
Okay, we'll excavate one.
We'll get at least $1000.
Alright, here we go.
We'll grab like...
We'll grab like one- a thousand dollars.
And then we're gonna try and find more mats.
Oh my god...
Where is it?
Please, I'm desperate.
I've been here for so long.
I'm going to travel all the way to this area.
I swear to God, I'm going to travel all the way right here to find this fucking thing.
I don't need any of this.
That's... I don't... I'll just take it.
I'll just take it.
I'll go all the way to that area.
Okay, we need to kill these guys anyway.
Whoa, whoa.
Do you self-destruct or something?
Okay, we need...
We need five more.
Five more crawlers.
Don't you need it for plumbing?
We haven't even made it to the part.
We're still trying to fucking decorate the pit.
Okay, we don't need the crawler shit here.
Somebody was here.
Like, I know somebody was here.
Okay, this is six.
Six one.
I should be allowed to buy materials.
I don't understand.
Oh, there is three.
Wait, that's good.
That's good.
That's good that there's three.
We need to kill as many as we can.
Okay, that's two.
Okay, one last one.
Not one last.
Two last.
Sorry, I can't count.
Okay, two more.
Oh my God, we're two more away.
Please.
How is there nobody here?
Oh, I can't jump because I'm tired.
I can't jump because I'm fucking tired.
And it's raining!
It's fine.
We don't care about the rain.
It's okay.
It's gonna be sunny again anyway.
Why is there nobody around me?
Is no one this deep into the... into the zone?
Is nobody else here?
Guys.
Guys, where... where is everybody?
Please.
Don't you all need a big bathroom too?
I can't be the only one here grinding out a fucking bathroom.
This can't be my... this can't be only me.
There has to be a...
Oh.
Wait.
Wait, where is... get over here.
Please.
No!
No, no, no, no, no!
You fucking...
You...
It's raining.
You fucking...
Current rainfall levels should not pose a problem.
Please.
I can't believe it.
So messed up.
Precipitation levels rising.
Precipitation levels decreasing.
I needed to scan you.
I needed to fucking scan you.
Please.
Wow.
Guys, literally...
And then it starts raining.
Oh my God.
Fifteen seconds until elevator arrives.
No friends.
Go to the...
I'm not walking all the way over here guys.
I'm not...
I'm not walking all the...
Guys, I am not walking all the...
Guys, I can't.
I cannot walk here.
I can't.
I cannot walk.
The next run, it will be...
We'll do the next run.
There's nobody here in this area.
There's not anybody in this area.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it!
You made it.
No, the next run won't be the last.
The next run is where we're going to make it.
The next run is the real one.
Guys, the next run is the real one, I swear.
I swear.
Okay, I don't want to see this.
It's just me going right.
It's me going...
I win.
Okay.
Alright.
There's no way.
There's no way to lock it that far.
Oh my god, please.
We're so close.
Somebody said it should have taken me an hour, like two hours ago.
They baited me so hard.
They baited me so fucking hard.
Just one more.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I got baited so hard.
They said it would be done in an hour.
Okay.
Alright, we need to find two more people.
And deliver the following amount of vicious stones.
I need...
Oh my god, I need that many?
Okay, we still need to get two more.
Wait.
What can I craft?
Oh, I can craft these.
Okay, I'm gonna repair then.
Repair.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
What can I... Okay, cradle parts.
Why can't you give me like materials?
Please.
Please, I just... Please, I just want like materials.
That's all I want.
Please.
I still don't have brittle iron ore.
I forgot to... Oh my god, I forgot that.
I... Oh my god!
This is the last run, guys.
This is the run where we're gonna get everything, I believe.
This is the run where we're gonna... we're gonna get everything we ever needed in life, guys.
I... I can feel it.
I can actually... I can feel it.
I can... I can feel it.
This is it.
I can craft iron ore?
With what?
What... How do I craft it?
Why didn't you tell me?
And it's raining!
Alright.
Guys, like, I... I'm going home.
I can apparently craft iron ore.
I'm fucking running back.
I'm fucking... I'm heading to the next exit.
I'm heading... I'm heading to the next exit right now.
I'm fucking... I'm ready.
I'm crafting this shit.
I'm crafting this shit and I'm fucking leaving.
I'm...
I'll grab some money real quick, too.
Dude, guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Don't worry.
There has to be another player somewhere near me.
I swear to god, if I get one, guys, I swear to god.
Target.
Oh!
There's a stone!
That's what we needed!
There's two!
Nice, we got two.
Nice!
We got two of that thing!
Where's the other target?
Oh, it's like behind... I'm not going there.
It's way too far.
Alright.
Alright, guys, we're fucking sca... Oh, wait!
Is that another one?
Nice!
Oh my god, we're getting all the stones we need.
This is it.
We're fucking rich for once.
For once, things are going my way.
Things are actually going my way.
Thank god.
God, I'm gonna cry.
Okay, we gotta jump here.
And then...
Is there anybody else here?
Is there anybody here?
Wait, how do I...
Wait, there's like a box somewhere, but is it below me?
Oh, it's below me!
It's fucking below me.
Wait, there's stuff here.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Is it here?
Oh, there it is!
Okay, nice.
Alright, we're crafting.
We'll craft the iron ore.
This is it.
We're gonna head back and we're gonna craft this stupid iron ore.
And then my...
Oh?
Is that him?
Guys!
I swear, I'm not suspicious, guys, please.
I...
Wait, where?
Where, where, where?
I can't hear them all.
Thank you for the...
Thank you, thank you.
Where is he?
I know you are...
I know you're a person.
Oh my god!
Please let me...
Please let me scan you.
Please, I...
Please...
Please let me...
Please let me scan...
Hi.
Hello.
Who are...
Who are fucking...
How do I...
Why can't I scan you?
Please!
I need to scan you!
Don't leave!
I...
I want that...
Please, I swear to god, I'm not suspicious, I...
I just...
Please, I just...
I just want to know what you are.
Please...
I swear, I'm not trying to kill you.
Please, I...
Oh, please, leave me alone!
I just want to scan him.
What?
I swear to god, I just...
Oh my god, please let me see you!
Why can't I watch you?
Is it the rain?
I swear to... oh my god, please, I'm going through a lot right now.
Where did he go?
I lost him!
No!
Oh, that's him.
Oh, he died.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, he's dead.
I'll take his blame.
I mean, I guess I'll just...
I'm outgunned now.
Wait, does he have iron ore?
How?
Why did I kill him?
He literally died!
Okay.
Let's see.
Wait, what's that behind me?
Oh, hey.
Hey, guys.
Guys, I... please, please, I...
Please, please, I... please.
Okay, nice.
Does he have iron ore?
No, he doesn't.
He doesn't have what I need.
How come I can scan that guy?
Oh my god.
Guys, they'll be fine.
We're fine.
We'll heal here.
We'll heal in the rain.
It'll, like, counteract it.
It'll counteract everything.
Oh my god, we did it, guys.
We fucking did it, everybody.
See, I told you guys.
It counteracts everything.
I don't know how he died, but now I have his gun.
He has some sick-ass guns, though.
Like, look at this.
Like, oh my god.
Look at...
He has a fucking bolt sniper rifle.
Like, I don't need to craft that anymore.
Oh, it's so far.
The weather's gotten better.
It's so far.
I don't know how she fucking died.
She has, like, loot.
That's the thing.
It was... Oh, we got...
Yeah, he died to the mobs and the rain.
Am I stuck?
Oh my god.
Damn it.
There's all...
No, there's no way.
There's no way I can jump out of this.
There's no fucking way.
There's no... Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I was gonna say, after all of that, and then...
I was gonna say, there's no fucking way they do this to me.
Like, I just want one thing.
I literally... I just want one thing.
Alright.
There we go.
We're fine.
We're safe.
We got her loot and then we, like, got a part of him inside me.
Look, see?
Look at that.
We have... Oh my god!
Wait, can I wear this?
I'm him!
Wait, I can have his arms!
Look at my fucking arms.
Look at that.
I didn't have to fucking do anything.
I got his arms.
Boink.
My arms now.
Oh my god.
Look, my arms are orange now.
I look like a gamer.
I'm not default anymore.
I look like a fucking gamer now.
We did it!
I'm tripped!
Oh my god, we did it, guys.
I left his legs.
I left his... I mean, he died, so, like, might not be very good legs in the end.
Like...
I'm off-gamer now!
I didn't even spend money for that!
I literally just stalked him until he died.
Okay, how do I... Okay, there we go.
Okay, this is it.
This is where we're gonna get our bathroom, ma'am.
We're gonna do this.
We're gonna get the bathroom, my lovely robot wife.
This is it.
There's no way I can fuck this up.
I got so many things.
I... I got so many... I'm a scavenger.
I'm literally a vulture.
I fucking stalked him until he fucking died.
It took all... It took most of his stuff.
This is it.
This has to be it.
Alright, what happened?
Who was it, anyway?
Is it him?
Oh yeah, he's the one that died.
Yeah.
Nerd.
At least I didn't die to the fucking rain.
All I'm saying is I didn't die to the rain, guys.
Like...
A lot of stuff happened, but at least I didn't die to the fucking rain.
Alright, this is it.
This has to be it.
There's no way.
There's no...
Oh my god.
There's no fucking way.
Oh my god!
She has the red... the red bodysuit now.
We've been granted permission to form alliances now.
Oh my god, that's how people get friends?
They finally unlocked friendship?
It only took three hours, guys.
It only took three hours and now I have friends.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that's all it took.
It took three hours to get friendship.
Friendship unlocked.
Nice, I got more money too.
Oh my god.
Finally.
I can finally have friends.
Oh, it took so long.
It took so long.
But we made it.
Okay, we gotta be able to...
Okay, we should be able to craft rocks apparently.
Materials.
Is it brittle iron ore?
Oh my god, we have enough.
Are you... one?
Okay, wait.
There's no way.
Can I craft more?
I...
Okay.
Your warehouse is full so you cannot...
I... what?
How much do... what do I have?
Holy shit.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta figure this out.
I did not realize.
I have a lot of stuff.
What do I sell?
And not just...
What the fuck do I have?
What do I sell?
I don't know what to sell.
How do I have so much stuff?
Press Z?
What does Z do?
Oh, Z the stack?
How?
No, it doesn't...
It doesn't stack.
Wait, it doesn't stack.
Unless I have to go...
Wait, how do I go to my warehouse?
Is it here?
Oh, it's here.
Okay.
Anyways, we'll be grouped together.
Oh, okay.
Oh, it's stacked.
Everything's stacked up.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright, that's good.
Nice.
Oh, five.
Oh my god.
Wait.
This is it.
This is so close.
We're actually so close.
We're so close.
This is it.
I knew this was the last one.
I have enough money.
Alright, you guys watch her fucking clean up.
I'm gonna use the bathroom again.
Did a pretty good job there.
With this complete, we can store just tons of equipment and supplies.
Starting to feel like you're a real drifter.
With the technical work done, now we can focus on making our space more livable.
With that said, next, let's focus on the living area.
There.
We made it.
We got the...
Oh my god.
Okay.
The degraded plaster piece.
And the fireplace.
I swear to god.
Do I...
Are we there?
Did we...
Are we close to the finish line?
Is it...
I would...
Oh my god.
Please.
We don't have the fusion core.
You fucking...
I swear to...
No.
We don't have a fusion core.
We can't craft a fusion core.
Score!
I know, I think it's so sad.
What the fuck do I do?
I'm an item manager.
And what was the item manager for?
Oh, what is it for?
I don't fucking pay for this.
Okay, okay, we can do this.
We get one last, one last job!
One last job!
Degraded plaster piece, what the fuck is that?
Okay, iron horde degraded.
Okay, one last, one last run!
One last job.
No, you don't understand, this is so important.
Okay.
Okay, degraded plaster piece and fusion comp.
Guys, one last job and we'll be there.
We'll be able to do the last job.
Oh my fucking...
I can feel it.
Okay, we're gonna put these guys away.
And then...
And then we'll put these guys away.
And then we should be good.
We should be good.
There's...
In the city, right?
In the city.
Alright, one last job.
This is it.
One last...
The...
The last heist.
The last heist!
This is it.
I can feel it.
I can feel the last job!
This is it, I believe.
No, you don't understand.
Guys, it will be so worth it!
It will be so worth it!
When we get it!
You have me at your side.
I'm at your side.
It will be fun.
It will be so worth it!
Alright, we have three bullets on the shotgun, but we don't need that.
We don't need that.
Where's the city?
Where the fuck...
Okay, the city is here.
Okay, one last job.
One last...
Guys, we don't need the shotgun!
We don't need it.
This is it.
Oh my god, how the fuck do I...
Oh...
Okay.
Okay, I fucked up a little bit, guys.
I hope I don't die.
I need it.
Okay.
No, you haven't lost me.
This is it.
Guys!
It's gonna feel...
It's gonna feel so good when we fucking do this.
When we...
It's gonna feel so good.
I swear to god.
That's fine.
Oh, a rare find.
Another rare find.
How many rare finds are we gonna fucking get?
Okay.
We don't need to deal with the people.
This is it.
This is fucking it.
If you're in my lobby, I'm in the fucking city.
I'm heading to the city ruins.
We don't need the crystals.
We know what we need.
We know what we fucking need.
Okay.
But what if I...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
He missed.
That's fine.
All right.
This is it.
We'll get a little bit of crystals.
I'm trying to get a little crystals.
All right.
We're getting a little bit of crystals.
Don't worry.
This is it.
We're so good.
We're right there.
We're heading to the...
Oh, shit!
No!
Ha-ha!
I forgot!
Oh, my god.
I forgot that was an abandoned boss.
I was like an abandoned boss.
Who cares?
Oh, my god.
That guy was so strong.
Holy shit.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're okay.
We're okay, guys.
It's like nothing bad happened.
It's like nothing bad happened at all.
Okay, nice.
Oh, hey, ammo.
Guys, look at that.
I found- I told you I can find ammo.
I told you guys.
Oh my god, why did it have to rain?
Like, I'm already going through a lot, please, ma'am.
Like, I'm already- I'm already going through a lot, please.
Like, we- guys.
Just one last job.
We'll be okay.
What the fuck is trying to shoot me?
Okay, we just gotta get rid of him.
Nice.
Okay.
It has to be- We're almost to the city.
The city ruins.
We're almost to the promised land.
They told me I can find so many scrap over there.
The promised land is so close.
The promised land.
No, this is the final heist.
The last job.
Son of a gun.
I'm in.
Okay, the city ruins.
It has to be here.
It has to be- Exactly.
They said this is where- They said this is where I can find the stuff.
Oh my god, maybe it's in the container.
Maybe it's in the fucking container.
It has- Is this one of those containers?
The fable containers?
No.
Oh wait, there is.
Okay, no, that's nothing I need, but okay.
Okay.
Please.
Alright.
There has to be stuff in the ruins.
There's crawlers?
I don't care about the crawlers.
Hello, are you- Please!
Please!
Please don't do this to me!
I- Please!
I went through so much!
Please, I swear, please.
Oh my god, please.
Please don't do this.
I'm just the fucking- I'm just trying to find my loot.
Why are you so evil?
Why are you so mean?
Oh my god, there's a target.
Oh my god, this is it.
Oh, I found one.
I found what I need here.
I'm just a little guy.
I- I'm just a little guy, please.
I swear to god, ow.
Oh, if he shoots me, I'm so fucked.
If he shoots me, I'm so fucked.
Oh, thank god.
Heal me, heal me, girl.
Okay, durability's partially back on track.
Okay, is this on my- is there my wishlist items?
I don't kno- no.
The city.
AO search.
I'm not detecting any new AO crystal pieces.
I'm just a little bird.
I'm trying- Durability has been reduced.
I'm trying to find the graded plaster piece.
I found the material where I- Oh, thank god.
This item is on our wishlist.
Our fusion core.
AO search.
I'm not detecting any new AO crystal pieces.
Wait, there's a- there's a chest here.
Container confirmed.
Okay, scrap.
Maybe they'll be good scrap.
We don't know that.
AO search.
I'm not detecting any new AO crystal pieces.
Any more?
Please.
We have arrived at the city rooms.
I'm working so hard for her.
This area is rich with resources.
I'm working overtime for my lovely anime wife robot.
No, why does it have to rain?
My- Please.
All she wants is to get clean.
I have to do overtime because she deserves it.
She deserves it.
AO search.
I'm not detecting any new AO crystal pieces.
She deserves everything in life.
The weather's gotten better.
It just rained for one second.
That's actually so fucked.
There has to be...
AO search.
Where is- I'm not detecting any new AO crystal readings.
Where is- Where is the- Oh my god, I literally need like degraded- Guys, where is the easiest place to find degraded plaster piece?
Is it still the city ruins?
Please tell me there's like another area.
Do it for her, guys.
Do it for her!
AO search.
AO crystal detected.
Nothing to note about size.
Training grounds?
Where the- Okay, training arena.
Okay.
Peter.
There it is.
Training arena.
Okay, we're gonna head to the training arena.
When we get there.
Oh hey, barrel crystals.
I don't know, maybe we'll need it in the end.
How do I get there?
How do I get out of this fucking hole that I dug myself in?
Hit confirmed.
Okay, nice.
Nice aim.
Ender has sustained damage.
Okay.
Pass me here.
Oh my god, how the fuck do I get out of this hole?
I'm behind- Oh my god, there's no- AO crystal detected.
Curity has passed.
The last dice.
No, there's no way to get out of this hole!
Wait, there is!
There is!
I'll jump for you!
I'll jump for you, ma'am!
This is it.
Guys, I can't get out of the hole!
I can't even get out of this hole!
I- City ruins.
I'll be stuck in the goddamn city ruins for 20 years.
What better place to escape?
I'll never leave the ruins.
I'll be here forever.
Keep on fighting a little longer now.
Wait, there it is!
There's up!
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's- Goddammit, it's regular plastic!
I don't need regular plastic!
I need- Though combat is unlikely, I'll analyze just in case.
I need fucking...
degraded!
Please, please, I'm so sorry.
The monsters are currently excavating AO Crystals.
Okay, you can have them.
Crawler defeated.
You can have it.
I'm just trying to get out of this pit.
I'm fucking baiting it up right now, trying to find the exit.
I'm trying to climb out of the fucking pit right now.
There's a target?
Oh my god, there's a degraded!
Oh, we did it!
Guys, we found one.
We- Why is the world so cruel?
I-
Oh shit!
Fuck!
Okay, there you go, it's fine.
It's fine.
Good target.
Okay, that's fine, man.
This isn't- I'm trying to get out of the city ruins!
I'm not even trying to be here anymore!
I'm trying to get out!
Oh my god.
How the fuck do I get the- God!
Oh shit!
Guys, when you pause the video game, it doesn't pause the game.
I don't know if you know that.
You can't pause the video game with that.
Oh my god, I feel like I've been stuck here for 20 years.
I- I- I- I- I- I - I- I- I- I- I- I- I - I - I- Please, I do.
Oh my god, I don't even want- I don't have ammo!
I've been stuck here for 20 years that I have to use up all my ammo!
I'm stuck here with the super chat.
How do I get to the training area?
Please, I need- I need three pieces.
I need three pieces.
Please!
Are you- Oh my god!
P-Tink-Tink.
Hello.
I wish I could pipe.
Sure.
Oh my god, do you have items?
Are you a dragoon?
Please drop your- Are you a dragoon?
Please drop- Please!
Please give me your fucking pipe!
Please!
Please, for the love of god, give me your pipe!
This is the only reason why I'm- No!
No!
They're just a regular person!
I don't want to do your fucking mission!
I'm trying to find my pipe!
I- No!
No!
You're just a regular fucking person.
Now to do your stupid fucking mission!
I- No!
No!
I don't want to do this stupid mission.
Oh my god.
Please- No!
No, not that!
Please, I'm sorry.
What, am I?
I'm sorry.
Please, don't do this to me!
I can't do this!
Oh my god.
Please, don't!
Oh my god, it was dumb.
Yes!
Oh my god.
Please, no!
Please!
Oh my god, I'm so sad.
No!
Shit!
I turned away!
Oh my god, I turned away.
Please, I'm going through so much more now.
Oh my god, I'll help.
I'll help.
Nevermind.
Okay.
Please, I have two bullets.
Please.
I have two bullets.
Don't do this to me.
Please, I have zero bullets.
I don't have the ammo.
Please.
I don't have friends.
Oh my god.
I thought I was on the triangle.
This is the only reason why I said yes.
It's so...
All missions complete.
Oh my god.
It doesn't even...
We'll work together again sometime.
He didn't even have the plastic piece.
Jesus Christ.
I'm thinking I'm going through so much right now.
I don't even have the ammo now.
This isn't fun.
I just wanted to do one last job.
You helped a friend in need.
What about me?!
Oh my god, please tell me, Oh my god, please tell me You have
What does it look like?
Are you serious?
He doesn't have... He doesn't have it!
And now it's... Oh my god, he doesn't have... Wait, it does?
It has fusion compound!
I need...
What do I need?
What is it called again?
Guys, what is it called?
I don't remember.
Wait, is there... What is it called?
I actually don't remember what it's called.
They created plastic piece?
Okay.
So this?
What does it look like?
No damage.
No, please.
I don't know what it looks like.
What does it look like, guys?
What does it look like?
What does the plastic piece look like?
I can't find it!
It's like a pipe.
Then it's not it!
It's a plastic... It's just a normal... It's just a normal plastic...
Oh, I should take the ammo.
You're right.
I should take the ammo.
I need this.
And I need... I need this.
Okay.
I knew it.
I knew they didn't have it.
I'll fucking take this though.
Fucking hell yeah.
Wait, I should take their... I should take their fusion compound.
Okay.
Oh, thank God somebody died here.
Thank fucking God.
Okay.
Thank God.
Holy shit.
At least I have zero ammo still.
Like... Oh, I should take their gun.
You're right.
I have ammo for their gun.
Okay.
I'm gonna take... Oh, I should take this shotgun.
And then I'll take their... What ammo do I have?
I have an assault rifle.
I'll take their assault rifle.
I'll take this.
I don't think they know.
I don't think... Oh, wait.
You're right.
I have to heal.
You're so right.
I'm going through so much right now.
I'm going through so fucking much right now.
Okay.
I have... Wait.
None of... Wait.
I don't have ammo for any... Oh, wait.
I do.
83.
Okay.
I'm gonna remove this.
At least I'll have ammo somewhere.
Alright.
Oh my God.
Oh no.
That's the... Okay.
We gotta not let that guy hurt us.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Is this... Is this another dead person?
Oh, it is.
It is.
Do you have ammo?
You don't have...
You do.
Oh my God.
He died to the rain.
And that's gonna be me.
Because I can't find cover.
Oh my God.
Please.
That's gonna be me.
Because I don't know where cover is.
Oh my God.
I have ammo.
I'm fucking rich.
We have hope.
I told you.
I told you, everybody.
This will be the last...
The last job.
The final heist.
Aluminum scrap.
I'll take that.
Okay.
I don't need any of this.
It's so close.
I can feel it.
Wait.
This is it.
Please.
Abandoned boss?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
There's no actual boss.
Abandoned boss.
Okay.
That's good.
Guys.
Okay.
This might not be the final, final job.
Because we still need to...
We still need to find the gun.
Guys.
Where is...
Where can I find degraded plastic piece?
Chat.
Where is...
Where is the place most likely for degraded plastic piece?
Is it actually the training area?
Do I have to go all the way over here?
It's all done.
Okay.
Alright.
New adventure.
Newest adventure.
All the way.
No.
It's fine.
This is it.
I told you.
The last job.
13 minutes is plenty of time.
It's plenty of enough time, guys.
This is the final job.
Okay.
We'll figure this out.
I swear to God.
If he shoots me after everything I've been through.
Please don't be that mean.
Oh, please.
Just pretend I don't exist.
Please.
We're so close.
We won't get killed by the raid.
There's still hope for us.
There's still so much hope.
It's gonna be so worth it.
You guys are gonna love what I'm gonna do after.
It's gonna be so worth it, guys.
Like, it's the journey.
It's the end that matters.
It's gonna be so worth it.
There's no way.
There's no way I did all that.
And then...
There's no way it'll be...
It'll be so worth it.
I can feel the bathroom.
I...
I detect the faint sound of an engine.
How did I not find a single fucking...
Oh my God.
I'm not going back to the city.
I can't.
I can't do this to myself.
I can't go back to the city, guys.
I... I can't.
I can't do the city again.
I'm... I cannot.
Okay, we're gonna go through this way.
This has to be the way to go to the training area.
There... There...
This has to be the only way.
How do I select it?
I can't move my map out of the area.
I... I can't.
How do I move it out of the area?
This is it.
I feel...
I feel it.
I feel it right here.
I'm almost...
Oh my God.
That's not what I need!
That is...
I heard... I found the material and I got...
I felt hope for like one second.
I legitimately felt hope for one second, guys.
I was like, oh my God, is that...
Is that it?
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
We're almost to the training area.
Holy shit, we're so close to the training area.
And we have an escape point right next to us.
Nothing can fuck with us now.
There... Oh my God, it's literally right there.
.....
Right there.
Nine minutes.
We have a training area.
The escape route is right next to us!
It's literally right next to us!
Okay, this is it.
This is it.
We're here in the train!
Am I here in the train?
Oh my god, I'm not even close to the training area yet.
Are you- are you fucking kidding me?
Like...
Are you fucking kidding me?
I have to walk all the way there.
It's okay.
Okay, give a five-minute walk mark.
We're gonna have to run to the escape port.
This is it.
We're here.
Where- where is it?
Where are the materials?
Where is the materials that I must seek?
Where are the materials that I seek?
Please, no.
What the fuck is that?
Okay, alright, we walk this way now.
We walk this way now.
Okay.
We walk this way.
Alright, that's- that's fine.
Wait, is that- is that it?
Oh my god, is that- it's a sniper rifle grade bullshit!
It's a sniper rifle grade- aww, I don't have cover because there's fucking holes everywhere!
There's like holes everywhere!
How is there no- I swear, I went to the training area.
I swear to god, there's- there's other stuff!
There's other stuff!
Is this cover?
I can't, I'm too tired.
I'm overheated.
I can't even get cover if I want to.
I'm too tired.
Okay.
This is- this is a grenade.
This is a frame.
Oh my god, there's you.
I need two.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
Don't worry.
There has to be just- no, no, no!
We're gonna do this!
We're gonna find- we're gonna find it.
At the five minute mark, we'll leave.
Oh my god, I'm just gonna get to this.
We lost it.
It's too easy.
We're so close, guys.
At the five- we leave at five minutes!
We'll make it to the extraction point when we have five minutes of that!
Okay, we'll extract.
After our last job, we are literally missing two more.
Are you ser- please stop raining on me!
Oh my god, maybe by the time I head home, maybe I'll- maybe I'll- Oh, thank you!
The graded plastic pieces!
You know, maybe- maybe it'll happen!
Maybe it'll happen.
You don't know.
Oh my god, there's a container here.
Oh my god, maybe there's plastic pieces.
There's- there's just waste gra- oh, that's fine.
I- I didn't need that.
That's fine.
Why is it still raining?!
Why?!
Oh my god, I just realized I can't- Oh my god, I have to get out of here to get there because that's a military base!
Oh my god, please.
It's literally right here.
I've been- I've been trapped in this world for so long.
I'm overheated, I'm tired.
I- I need- Oh my god, Andy!
Andy, are you- are you- please, Andy, I wish I could just type in chat and be like, please, plastic pieces, please.
I just wanna type in chat and be like, plastic pieces, please.
This is a rough world.
This is such a rough world.
It's so rough.
Oh my god.
Guys- guys, one last job.
The- the last- the final last job.
I swear to god.
I swear.
In between the road tunnels?
Where's west?
On the west side?
That's left side.
Why did you make me go to the training area?
What do you mean?
This is the west side!
Where would it be on the west side?
Okay.
This is the west side!
The- the- the- the east side!
This- this is the west side!
Okay, guys.
It's making me laugh.
Holy.
It's making me laugh!
That's the east side!
That's the east side.
Mom!
We're actually so close!
Trust me, guys.
Like...
It's gonna be so worth it.
I swear to God, it's gonna be so worth it.
I swear to God.
I swear.
Okay, how fucked up were we?
Look at this adventure we had.
Oh my God.
Where were we?
We explored the entire world.
This is when she fucking tricked me into doing her fucking mission.
Oh my God.
Holy shit.
I went everywhere.
I actually went everywhere.
I fucking went everywhere.
No wonder, for real.
This is my whole journey.
My actual journey.
Okay.
Alright, what did I get?
I'm gonna buy better legs.
I can't.
I need to buy better legs.
I was not fucking...
Oh, I completed a request.
Nice.
I went everywhere.
Oh my God.
We're so close.
It's literally...
Oh my God.
It's literally right there.
It's...
No!
It's okay.
We're so close to the end.
Okay, repair everything.
Okay, we gotta put stuff away though.
We have too much useless junk here.
Okay, we're gonna...
Which one's best?
68%.
64%.
Oh wait, this is better.
Wait, what?
No, 7000.
Wait, which is better?
Whoops.
Firing speed.
Oh no, this is better.
The one I fucking stole is so much better.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Okay, and then which one is this?
Okay, firing speed.
I guess we'll go with this.
Alright.
Wait, no.
Wait, this is...
This is green.
Alright, we're gonna put...
Wait, what the fuck is this?
You know what?
Fuck it, we're sniping.
Might as well.
Okay, get all this in here.
Get all this in here.
We're never gonna have no ammo.
Alright guys, we have to...
We have to make legs.
I can't anymore.
Like, I have to have legs.
I...
I need feet.
Better feet.
Okay, purchase restrictions.
One out of one.
230...
200...
300 and...
Alright.
Boost speeds.
Okay, this should be better.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Birds.
We're...
We should be okay now.
Right?
We're...
We have weather resistance.
Alright.
Guys, we don't need heal.
Okay, we need heal.
Let's win.
Okay.
How...
What can go wrong?
What can go wrong now?
Alright.
How is there...
Oh my god, we're so close.
We just need two more degraded plaster piece.
Guys, where is the plaster piece again?
Guys, I need to know where...
Where...
Where is the plaster piece, guys?
I...
This is really...
I'm like at my wit's end here.
I need to know.
Okay, left side of the map.
Okay, we gotta ensure everything.
Okay, apply all...
Okay, a thousand dollars.
Okay.
This is it.
This has...
God dammit, I'm in.
God dammit, I'm fucking in, guys.
Oh my god.
It's really the last job.
God fucking dammit.
The final last score.
The last ride.
Look at me.
Oh my god, look at my arms.
Where did I spawn?
Oh, thank fucking god I spawned there.
Okay, we're gonna run here and then maybe...
This has to be it.
There's no other way.
There's no other... oh my god, I'm so fast.
Okay.
Holy shit, why did I not upgrade sooner?
Gotta go this way.
Yeah, we're zooming now.
We're so zooming.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Oh my god, I fucking hit it.
Holy shit.
That was strong.
Wait, is this... okay, we're grabbing... I don't know if we need this, but like I don't...
I don't know.
I'm too scared.
I don't know anymore.
I'm desperate.
Okay.
This is it.
Oh my god, and I can go on forever.
Look at how fast I go.
Okay.
Into the roads we go!
Okay, plastic pipe.
I'm just gonna grab this for now.
Who knows?
We might need it.
Oops, sorry.
This has to be it.
In the... in the... down here.
Hello, are you friendly?
Oh my god!
I know you do, Blaster!
Give me fucking Blaster right now!
No!
You're a jerk!
Yes, I recognize you!
Where's your Blaster?
What the fuck?
I swear to god, if you did... I swear to god, you did not bring Blaster, did you?
You didn't bring Blaster!
Oh, thank god, he got it.
Okay, I got it.
But this is not Blaster!
Oh, thank god, he has Blaster!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's a guy!
We fucking did it!
Holy shit, we fucking did it!
Oh my god!
Holy shit, how much was it?
What does it even look like?
Oh my god, he got me five things!
We fucking did it!
Oh, I don't choose the last job!
Oh my god, we can leave!
Oh my god, my dad still had to walk so far to get home.
And that's what I told you.
When he walked away, I almost thought he did not have it.
When he walked away, I thought he was just playing the game.
Oh my god, thank god he had it.
He actually had it.
I got so worried there.
I was like, there's no way.
There's no way you don't actually have it.
Oh my god, okay, we have to go this way.
The fakeout.
When he turned around, that actually fucked me up.
Alright, off we go.
You like my gun?
Thanks, I stole it.
No, I recognized the name.
I recognized Airborne Ninja.
I know he was a dragon.
But I legitimately thought he was fucking with me.
And was like, sorry, I don't have any.
Oh no, no, please.
Oh no, please, I overheated.
No!
Oh god, no!
Get out!
Analysis failed.
Oh god, please.
Hit confirmed.
We have caused significant damage.
Oh god, please.
Enemy has repaired their durability.
Live!
Alright, okay.
Calm down.
Calm down, need to get out of here.
Calm, calm down.
Calm down.
I need to get out of here.
Oh my god, please.
Please, we're stuck.
I swear.
Oh my god, we're almost there.
I'm running as fast as my legs can take me.
My little legs.
My little fucking legs.
Oh, we're here.
We're here.
Return request transmitted.
Oh my god, thank god.
Thank fucking god.
Don't you dare, kiddo.
Don't you dare.
Please, I worked so hard for this last job.
Please.
Oh my god, I can feel the finish line.
Oh, there he is.
What if I shot him?
If I wouldn't, I wouldn't do that though.
We worked so hard.
Don't do it.
He worked so hard.
Wee!
This is a group effort chat.
Worked hard.
Oh god, okay.
This was a group effort.
Oh my god, please.
I swear to...
We did it, guys.
We did it.
Oh my god.
I'm so happy.
Oh my god, this is it?
Did we make it?
Guys, this was supposed to be a one hour stream.
But like...
We don't need to watch this.
We know what happened.
Oh my god.
This is it.
I believe.
This has to be it.
What else do I need?
This...
You can't make the bathroom gonna cry.
You're gonna cry?
Oh my god.
Alright, here we go.
Complete.
Today's the perfect day to get started on the living area.
This is it.
You never even begin to tell you how long I've waited for this.
How long you've waited?!
...
I want a bath and a huge sofa and I am getting rid of that grimy mattress as well as that, and that, and those.
I have lots of work ahead.
But feels good to have someone like anyways.
It feels good to have someone like.
What did she do?
That's it?
The mattress is still there!
The mattress is...
At least we recycled.
I like how she was like...
Thank god we can finally replace the mattress and it's still there.
It's literally still there.
I...
There's no fucking way.
Guys, be truthful to me.
How much do I need?
How much?
Oh, I can craft it.
Wait, I can craft it.
Wait, really?
Can I actually craft it?
Don't fuck with me.
No, I cannot, you fucker.
You...
Why did you give me hope?
Why the fuck did you give me hope?
That's so fucked up.
Oh my god.
Guys, give it to me straight.
How much more do we need?
Jenner says thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The Last Sight saga continues.
Thank you for the super...
You're so close.
How much?
Guys, just give me the number and I'll find it all on the list.
The next one.
Just give me a number.
I need to know how much I need to find.
I need to know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We need some bathroom anyway.
I invested four hours.
I invested four fucking hours.
I'm almost...
Oh my god.
What?
Who told me about the bathroom?
Who the fuck told me about the goddamn bathroom?
What the fuck?
I blame the person that told me about the fucking bathroom.
I wouldn't be here if I didn't know.
Oh my...
Guys, please give it to me straight.
How many materials do we need?
How many materials?
Oh my god.
We'll just watch our wife fucking clean, I guess.
Lunar, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
When the one hour bathroom turns into a four hour bathroom.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I need a number.
Guys, I can't.
I can't.
Like, you just grab the necessary...
Give me a number.
I need the number of materials.
I don't think the next one is the bathroom.
That's what's so fucked.
I don't think this is the bathroom.
Five.
Five what?
You can't just...
You can't give random...
Five what?
What do I need?
What the fuck do I need?
I'm doing everything for her.
I'm doing everything for this girl.
Okay.
Okay, this is the last run.
This will be the last run.
This will be the last fucking run.
Oh my god.
How many upgrades?
Guys, how many fucking upgrades?
How many upgrades left?
Oh my god.
The last job.
God damn it.
I'm fucking in.
I'm fucking in on this last job.
Guys, I don't think it's raining.
I don't think it's the last...
Oh my...
Where am I?
Oh, thank god.
I'm next to the city.
The game knows.
The game fucking...
I didn't even enshrine.
I didn't enshrine.
I went straight in.
I'm so fucking...
Oh my, I'm going crazy.
I didn't even enshrine.
Alright.
Okay, I just wanted to get rid of this guy.
Oh my god.
There has to be the fusion core here.
This is the city.
I'm in the ruins.
Okay.
Alright.
I can see the materials?
Where?
Wait, how do you guys see the materials?
How do you do it?
Okay.
Fusion core is here.
I know because I was here.
I did so much to be here.
Alright, I don't need the crystals.
I literally...
Caution?
Wait, the drifters die here?
Why did I get caution?
Oh!
Up down?
Oh my god, this is it.
Oh my god.
Oh my fucking god.
Okay.
We're gonna find our fusion core.
We have copper scrap.
Where the fuck is the fusion core?
I'm in the area.
What do you mean it's over there?
Did they take it?
Oh my god.
It's just... It's just this.
Please.
Please don't.
I don't have insurance.
Please leave me alone.
Please.
I don't have insurance.
I... Please.
Oh my god.
He's friendly.
He's jumping.
But I don't know if he's baiting me.
I don't know.
I found the material we're after.
Oh my god.
Oh.
It's a dragon.
Oh my god.
Who are you?
Who are... Oh fuck.
Give me... Give me... Give me... You have... Give me everything.
You know how many materials there are.
Give me... You must have more.
You must have more.
There has to be more in your fucking inventory.
There has to be more, Alan.
You don't understand.
I'm desperate.
I'm so desperate.
I need the bathroom for my wife.
I need... I need the bathroom.
I'm so desperate.
Oh, please.
Will you...
Oh, do you... Oh, you had something.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
All right.
That's fine.
Okay.
I'm happy.
I'm going to leave.
Okay.
Where's the closest...
All right.
Now fight each other.
Fight each other.
Oh, my god.
Nice.
Okay.
All right.
What does he have?
Okay.
He has...
Oh, look at that!
Yeah, that's a cool head.
Okay, I'll get this.
And then... oh my god, look at this arm.
And then I'll grab these too.
Alright, nice.
Wait, did it drop more?
Do you have more?
Please, I'm so desperate.
Do you have more, please?
Please, she wants so much.
This is fine, I have more than enough.
Where we can... okay, we gotta go this way.
This is where... this is... this is... this is where... where... oh my god, is that the way I have to go?
This is where...
Alright, this is where we have to go.
Oh my god, I went through so much.
I... I... I went through so much.
Oh my god, it might piss you off.
I... oh my god, I don't care anymore.
Anything for her.
The things I do for her.
Okay, is this better?
360... oh wait, no, mine's better.
The guy that fucking jumped to his death.
Oh my god, we're so close.
This has to be it.
There's no way... I'll do it for her.
Do it for her.
Oh my god.
We're so close to the finish line.
Okay I have to go this way.
Try to figure out where to go.
Okay, I go this way and then I turn around.
Alright.
This is it.
It's alright.
We should have enough now.
We literally have... there's no way!
Look at this!
There's no way she wants more.
I gave you everything.
I don't have a life anymore.
I gave you all I have.
What more do you want?
I don't even have friends anymore.
I don't have friends.
I do all of this for you.
I...
But I just have a broken man.
Oh my god.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh my god, please don't do this.
How the fuck are you not dead?
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Who's this?
Extortion Blackmail Priory.
All for her.
It's all for you.
Number three.
Oh my god, here it is.
This is it.
Oh my god, this is it.
What?
What more do you want from me?
A chaser?
How the fuck is he so far away?
How did that detect me?
Alright, we're fine.
Oh my god.
This has to be it.
There's no other...
There's no way.
This has to be it.
Okay.
Alright, we don't need to see this.
We don't need to see this.
Okay.
Let's go.
There's no way.
What more does she want from me?
Okay, walls and ceiling.
I'm so tempted to quick fill ten seconds.
Okay.
We got the walls and ceiling.
The next one has to be the bathroom, right?
Nothing like a little weeding to start the day.
Starting to feel less like amagus and more like a...
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, even...
Oh...
Oh!
Weed soup!
Let's go!
I work... I work...
7 to 9 with overtime.
And then my wife, RobiAnimeGirl, makes me weed soup.
What a life.
What... What a life.
You can actually see the ceiling display at long last.
Next up on our list is the one we've all been waiting for.
Oh my god!
Yes!
Oh my...
This has to be it!
The next one on the list we've all been waiting for!
Oh shit!
I can craft that!
Oh thank god!
I was gonna fucking freak out.
I was gonna fucking freak out if I have to.
Oh thank fucking god I can craft this.
This is it!
Oh my god!
This is actually it!
We were here!
We were fucking... You know, fucking...
I can't wait 8 seconds.
I literally cannot.
I cannot wait 8 more seconds.
Oh my god!
We were here!
Now, let's get started on that dream bathroom.
What do you say?
Oh my god!
Yes!
That goes there.
Four hours and...
The one... I told you the last job!
Fuck!
Okay.
It's finished.
Bathroom.
It's beautiful.
It is.
Look, this is a lot better than nothing, alright?
This is four hours of work.
This was...
This is four hours.
It's so round to work.
You look like a magus you wouldn't be embarrassed to be seen with?
I feel...
No, there's no way!
There's no way that's it!
Please!
Oh my god!
What is this?
Perform cleaning?
Cleaning?
Wait, what?
You got it wrong!
This is it!
Pay the ones!
I can't believe it!
Oh my god!
I paid a thousand dollars!
She's my wife!
I was just not...
That's it!
I have to pay my wife a thousand dollars.
There's no way!
There's no way that's all!
I got out of it...
What are you...
That's...
It's a new cutscene!
I need a thousand dollars to watch it!
A thousand...
Oh my god!
There's no way.
I need like another... I need her to do it again to make this worth it.
I can't.
I need her to clean herself for every hour.
For every hour.
JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I paid her $4,000 just to clean herself.
How many times?
Four hours per minute.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I need one more.
The fourth hour just to commemorate.
The fourth hour.
Guys, if you want a bathroom, make sure to check us in UALITY when it comes out.
I did it.
You're so... you're beautiful.
You're so beautiful.
I better as well get the lounge.
Go for it.
Go.
I can't believe I even quick-filled it too.
I hate it.
Oh my god, Popro, thank you for the...
You want to give the chips?
Thank you, thank you.
You're so beautiful and clean.
Anything for my robot anime girl wife.
Goodbye to this old piece of plastic.
And we'll put the sofa here.
Thing is, people nobody, if they knew...
That's the hard part.
You kind of knew.
You told me, they were four hours.
The garage really has come a long way.
This calls for a celebration.
Nice.
Bye-bye, guys.
At this point, this garage has the bare minimum of everything a drifter needs.
Yay!
The bare minimum!
All future renovations to your discretion, my igniter.
Let's build a base of operations worthy of...
Wait, if I upgrade the bathroom more, does the cutscene last at least longer?
Like... like that's... I need...
What the fuck?
Not to fucking give you a kitchen and a piggy...
You don't need a fucking piggy bank!
You wanna...
What the... where did all of this come from?
Where did all of this...
What the fuck, where did all of this come from?
Oh my god!
Why do you need a piggy bank?
I don't understand!
What the fuck, we need an elevator?
We need a fucking elevator!
Oh my god.
Alright guys, we're gonna call it here.
We... we did a lot today.
We really did a lot.
That was... that was fun.
Thank you again for...
Bandai for sponsoring me today.
Chat.
Thank you to Bandai for the sponsor.
We...
We got so far.
We even paid for insurance too.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
We did it.
Our anime wife...
Robot wife is happy.
We... we did it.
We did it for her.
We did our one last job.
Thank you everybody.
I hope you guys check out Sinuality when it comes out.
Chat.
It was great.
I had...
It was fun though.
It was fun.
I hope you guys enjoyed the ride.
I'm gonna...
I'm fucking...
I'm gonna call it here.
Thank you everybody.
Please check out Sinuality.
And thank you again for...
Bandai for the sponsor.
Happy wife.
Happy life.
I'm so happy.
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you as always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause the chat.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.